I've got some new tour dates to tell you
about I will be back in Atlanta jaw jaw
at the Fox Theater I loved it so much
I'll be there on April 4th tickets go on
sale this week get yours early with code
Rat King starting Wednesday January 10th
at 10:00 a.m. local time we also have
tickets remaining in
Brisbane um in the Australia
Sydney uh in the Australia as well
Charlottesville State College Amhurst
all of those available at theo.
comom and make sure you get your tickets
through there if you're looking at some
ticket that's an insane price 500 so
17,000 then you're on some weird site
and that's that's your issue um but yeah
if tickets are too expensive for you at
whatever's remaining or on SEC or on a
secondary site just wait we'll come back
through I don't want you blowing your
bank out man uh thank you guys for the
support today's guest is uh the man
that's one way to put it he's the number
one life strategist uh on the globe on
Earth um he's a philanthropist he's an
entrepreneur he's a bestelling author um
there's there's nothing really that he
hasn't done he is an inspiration to many
he's worked with some of the most
intriguing and successful people on
Earth um as an adviser to them uh I feel
lucky to get to sit down with him and
spend some time today's guest is Mr Tony
[Music]
Robins I'll sit and tell you my
stories
sh
me and I will find a song how this
[Applause]
yeah man thanks so much dude really
really cool great to be with you yeah
you too man so many of my friends are
fans of yours and that's how I became a
fan got to listen to you and laugh my
tail off here thanks you really bring a
different color to things it's fantastic
yeah I don't know what we're doing a lot
of times you know that's that's when you
do your best right yeah it just flows it
just flows yeah you know yeah I guess it
is man yeah that's true actually it's
weird how much you can kind of plan and
then but if you can show up with a level
of unplanned kind of like spontaneous is
always much more funny and and much more
powerful I think yeah yeah yeah I guess
you because you probably because you do
so many things I mean even after just
seeing and hearing a lot about you
online and and just over the years you
do so many things to try and fine-tune
yourself right would you is that a safe
safe way to say that yeah and know and I
have certain fundamentals I want to
cover but every time you enter an
audience and you got 15,000 people you
know and you got to hold them for 12s
hours a day for five or six days when
they wouldn't usually sit for you know a
30 minute you know video or three-hour
movie so you got to really be able to
adapt and feel what's there just like
you and adapt and and it's got to be
funny I mean if all you do is get up and
talk for 12 hours you want to kill
yourself right so you got to make people
laugh you got to move them you got to
produce all those things because you
know time is so relative like how long
is a long time some people think well
you know Thousand Years some people
think 2 minutes right so a long times
when you're not enjoying yourself you
know a minute feels like you turn
but if you're fully engaged and you're
enjoying everything like 12 hours goes
like that so it's it's fun to see the
impact you can have with people when
you're willing to adopt it was the same
every time also I'd be bored out of my
mind just like it's your Live Events you
mean yeah yeah yeah yeah that's I mean
it's definitely remarkable um yeah I
think I was thinking about like like
tuning like more just like in your
regular life and like your uh being
ready for the day like yes what is that
tuning like for you cuz that's a
constant like that that's always
evolving like every couple of months now
we hear about some new thing or some new
method or somebody's you know people are
hiding underground for two hours or
whatever people are you know there's
people like who you know you know won't
let their Shadow outside for a month and
it's supposed to help them process lymph
or whatever you know so there's there's
so many things and um what are some
things that that you that you do or that
that really make you feel like uh that
didn't feel like snake oil kind of you
know yeah well you know some things I do
I've been doing for like 20 years like
you know I start every day in a cold
plunge now it's very popular uh you know
ice bath and so forth but I don't
there's never a day I look forward to it
Theo I don't wake up and go I can't wait
to freeze my ass off but I to me it's a
discipline it's like training my mind
besides the physical benefit you know it
doesn't feel good when you go in but you
feel amazing coming out you're entire
body gets flooded right your liy your
blood moves but going in it's like I
don't negotiate with myself I don't go
oh let me see if I'm ready it's like
I've trained my brain I say go we go and
my home in Sun Valley I I walk through
the snow and get in the river yeah you
know that's like you know
41° and I mean it's it's intense but
when you train your brain that when I
say go go no negotiation then that shows
up in every other part of your life so I
do that I you know I work out every day
obviously I do a 10-minute process it's
a it's not really a meditation because
I'm not good at not thinking and I don't
know many people are that have no
thoughts but I I do a way to kind of
condition my nervous system and my mind
it's really simple I do these three
pieces three minutes each it's only 10
minutes so if I said 20 minutes people
say I don't have time but even have 10
minutes for your life you don't have a
life right so I just do three minutes of
what are the emotions that mess people
up in their relationship or their
business it's usually anger or fear some
derivative of those two so the antidote
to those is gratitude you can't be angry
and grateful simultaneously right you
can't be fearful and grateful
simultaneously so I train my nervous
system by starting every morning I do
this process to change my body it's a
breathing process and then I think of
one at a time a minute each I see and
feel something in my life that I'm
really grateful for I do little things
and big things so you don't have to have
a giant thing to be grateful yeah and
it's real it's not like I'm seeing it
over there it's like I'm experiencing it
so it changes your biochemistry So when
you say experience in it not to
interrupt you yeah no go interrup as
much you want but no I just want because
I'll forget what the question is that's
the only reason it's like it's like a
desperation be um yeah so in that moment
like CU I know what you're talking about
I'll make a gratitude list right but
sometimes it's like I'm just writing the
things down and there's no real
connection inside of me that won't do
much and I know it won't do it's like I
know this going to help at least I'm
doing the practice but I know it's not
going to have like a I I can tell even
right now it's not going to help me that
much so what are you saying that I that
that I'm saying I close my eyes you know
sometimes if I said think of a time when
you rode a roller coaster and you
remembered over there like see it over
there that's called disassociated but if
I get you imagine being in the front
seat and you might tell me oh that was
pretty interesting but if I get to go
back actually the moment when you're
coming over the edge and then you you
see even right now you can see oh you
know so that's what I do do with the
Gratitude I get in my body as if I was
then see it and feel it and experience
it and that creates a biochemical change
in your body as opposed to a thought a
thoughts not enough right yeah so and
you do three of those and then I have
three minutes of kind of a cleansing of
my body that I do mentally and and a
kind of a prayer for others and then I
do three minutes of what I call you know
three to thrive I think of three things
I want to make happen outcomes results
and I don't sit there and beg for them
or pray for them I see them as done I
feel them I celebrate them as done
because when your subconscious mind it's
done it makes it happen so it's kind of
programming it and the whole thing only
takes 10 minutes if anybody wants to do
it they can go to tonyrobbins.com
priming there's no cost for it and shows
you how to do it but we do it with you
know 20,000 people in a stadium and the
energy that you have at the end that's
amazing because otherwise you wake up
and what do you have the first thing is
your phone and your phone has a mixture
of things really you know if you have
you know like you do a lot of
responsibilities and companies and P I
look at that thing oh oh it's like it's
you you're not in control of your life
so I I set my life first I Prime what I
mean by priming is priming is a
psychological principle a lot of times
when people Theo think something think
oh that's my thought but it's been
primed by something in the environment I
got give you an interesting study they
did this at Harvard they took uh men and
women trained them as actors they went
out and did this very simple thing they
would go out to people and they have a
cup of coffee and they rehearse doing it
the exact way every time they walk up to
you doing it yeah they're doing it the
mall or someplace else they see you
sitting there and they go excuse they go
excuse me or University campus and
they're holding a coffee they could you
hold this for a second and they don't
ask they put in your hand they look down
so 90% of people take it and they
reached in the pocket did something with
their phone thanks so much that's it
walk away well half those people they
did that with had hot coffee the other
half had cold ice coffee so then 15
minutes later approximately 15 to 20
minutes later somebody comes by and they
have this little sheet you know
clipboard and they say hey I've got $20
if you'll give me 60 seconds of your
time would you take 20 seconds to read
the this little paragraph of a story and
then tell me afterwards I have two
questions they read the story and they
say okay tell me what was this person
like how would you describe this
character well the person that that the
coffee person you mean the no they don't
remember that person it's been gone from
the story now it's a new person okay 20
bucks most people do it 20 bucks for a
minute okay I'll do it some people say I
don't need the 20 bucks I'll just answer
your question read this little story
it's the same same story for everybody
yeah and then they asked him afterwards
how would you describe the main
character the people that got hot coffee
81% of them say the person is warm and
generous when they give them the iced
coffee they don't even know it affected
them 80% 1% difference is variable will
say the person is cold or uncaring no
way same story that's absolutely true oh
my gosh you can do it you can do this
with creativity if I said to you make if
I talk to an audience I'll say make the
sound of what you think of when you
think of Microsoft and you get uh make
the sound of apple right that's a
trillion dollar difference in people's
response so they've done creativity
tests well that have people watch a
30-second Apple commercial or just look
at the Apple logo and then look at an
IBM commercial or an IBM logo 20% higher
score on a creativity test they take
right after that for those who just
looked at the Apple commercial that's it
so we can be influenced so powerfully so
I decide I want to advertise in my own
mind I'm not going to have somebody else
take control and so I prime myself every
day I prime my brain so it's in a
grateful State it's an anticipatory
State it's a moving State because
otherwise you get whatever you feel like
and I don't know about you there are
days I wake up I what city I'm in you
know my body's gone I've got 3 hours
sleep on a time zone so if I didn't
reset then it'd be fake I'd be getting
up trying to talk to people and I'm not
really you can't move people if you're
not moved you can't touch people if
you're not touched you can't make people
laugh if it doesn't make you laugh right
you know yeah that's true that's really
true so I try to make sure I'm in that
place every single day and then when you
do it every day it trains your nervous
system to look for things to be grateful
for then your mind starts to become
conditioned because most people is that
true that's absolutely true if you don't
there just habits right so if you don't
use your mind your mind will use you
it's like technology right you use
technology do amazing things or you can
let your technology start using you with
your whole life is control gambling on
your phone even yeah for sure and that's
just you could be doing anything God
It's upsetting um I mean I've I've been
obviously I have blockers on my phone
now because obviously I can't you know
whatever but um but that's amazing no
that's something I don't that we don't
think about a lot is like instead of
just looking at the world why don't you
clean the weapon that you're looking at
the world with you know you got it cuz
people think of it this way Theo people
don't experience life they experience
the life they focus on right so right
now there's a if you're happy you are
deleting all the things you could be
pissed off about or frustrated or
worried about in the world if you're
unhappy you're deleting all the things
that are great in your life Wow and our
brains delete and they distort and they
generalize so if you don't direct it you
get whatever shows up what's wrong is
always available what's wrong in the
world it's always available what's wrong
right is also available it's just which
one you pick and it isn't about positive
thinking cuz I I've never been into
positive thinking people think I that's
what I do it's not I believe in
intelligence and so when you're in a
lousy State of Mind you treat people
poorly you don't perform at the highest
level you're not happy when you're in a
great state of mind to treat people
better perform at a different place and
it's one of the reasons the humor is so
valuable it changes People's State and
then you know all of a sudden they're in
a different place they respond in a
different place when they're laughing
then when they're pissed off so why not
train yourself to do that you've trained
yourself to find what's entertaining or
funny and just about anything is what
makes you as good as you are in that
area you have developed patterns of how
to do it you may not even be conscious
of them all yeah I don't think I was I
don't think there were conscious
patterns but I think sometimes the
sometimes yeah the best part is when my
brain will make me laugh and I didn't
even have anything to do you know like
cuz after a while yeah you're like and
you're like I'll sometimes I'll just
bust out laughing I'll be like thank you
so much like like my brain like just
like does like a little joke for me or
something um and this this goes right
into something I was I was thinking
about since it's like the new year you
know and happy New Year to you and um
and yeah cuz people so often say like
New Year's resolution or they're like
but that doesn't really that's kind of
like a oneandone it feels almost
outdated that idea but how do you CH I
guess and you just kind of answered I
guess like how we change our perspective
so like so we change our attitude you
know that's really what you need to have
a new experience yeah you there's three
decisions you're making every moment
your life your audience can test this
out the first one is what going to focus
on now when I say make these decisions
Theo I don't mean you're making them all
consciously right so whatever you focus
on that's what you feel if you're
supposed to meet your boyfriend
girlfriend husband wife whoever at 7
o'cl you get there at 700 they're not
there some people are pissed off some
people are worried it's the same event
if it's 7:30 and they're not there
they've not called they not text now
what are you feeling some people go I'm
really pissed off I'm really worried I'm
really single you know really single I'm
it's 8:30 haven't showed up I'm full I
didn't wait for the bastard you know but
the point is whether whether you're
angry or whether you worried had nothing
to do with the event it's the habits of
your mind the person who's worried
thinks oh maybe they're in a car
accident person's pissed off they did it
again so the first decision you make is
what are you going to focus on and most
people have patterns of focus so there's
three I'll give you your audience can
test out do you tend to focus more on
what you have or what's
missing what's missing yeah do you tend
to focus more on what you can control or
what you can't
control probably what I can control
because but it's out of desperation
because I feel like I have to control
everything well that's not a bad thing
you can't control everything right it's
an illusion but you can influence so
much you can control everything in you
okay and then the third one do you tend
to tend focus more on the past the
present or future the past yeah so those
three patterns if you do all three of
them if you constantly look at what's
missing it's hard to ever stay fulfilled
or happy yeah so you have to always do
something to try to make yourself happy
because you're always noticing what's
missing that's just where your focus
goes there's always something missing
there's always something that's not
missing there's always something
beautiful if you focus on what you have
you're going to be more fulfilled second
one if you focus on what you can control
what you do it's why you have your own
business it's why who you are but a lot
of people focus on what they can't
control it's overwhelming they're
stressed out they think of all those
things so if you constantly focus on
What's Missing You can't control and the
past which you can't change what that
makes is either angry or sad or
frustrated or depressed I've you see
people all the time that come to me you
know groups I just did this thing for
Stanford where they two years ago and
everybody's in covid they came to me
because two of their professors came to
my seminar for 5 days both were you know
clinically depressed they came back with
no depression symptoms they said you
know how do you do this I mean do you
have any data I said well I got millions
of people my programs you know they go
no like scientific dat I said well you
want to do a test they said sure I said
what do you want to test on and they
said depression and I said well I
already know what triggers that for
anybody you can give them drugs all day
long all Prozac and Zola does is numb
things but I just got off of mine oh
good for you yeah I'm like 17 days off
right now so awesome well let's see how
it goes see how it goes I appreciate it
but but your two patterns that you just
did constantly Focus what's missing and
the past will make it a little harder
for you to be happy on a long-term basis
you crack yourself up so in the moments
you change your state but if you want a
long-term change all you'd have to do is
change the Habit it's just a habit of
focusing on what you do have like your
life is magnificent yeah yeah I got to I
try a lot I just have to make sure I do
well it has to get conditioned
and so it's you don't have to about it
if you think about it doesn't work right
by that time it's too late and then the
second one is focusing on what you can
control your already do but the past
versus the present and the future
enjoying the present and building the
future just that little pattern changed
somebody's life do you know how many
people are on Prozac and so off I'll ask
in an audience I got 15 20,000 people I
say how many of you know someone who's
on anti-depressants and they're still
depressed and 95% of the room raises
their hand and the reason is because
those drugs numb you but they don't
charge the cause as long as you
constantly focus on What's Missing From
my life and constantly look at the past
which you can't control and if you're on
top of it you're focused on you know
what you can't control that's why I got
off cuz I I could have any feelings I
was trying to like be in relationships
and stuff and it's like girls would be
like do you like me I like I don't you
know
like I would literally have to look at
like history of Stu like it's almost
like I would have to look at my own past
for Clues right like on how I felt and
so because you're being altered right
you're being altered
yeah it was just too it was too hard to
get like a real feeling out of myself
and so I was like man I got to have some
feelings or I'm not going to be able to
make some choices for myself good for
you that's really awesome but I want you
to know I want you to know how the
normal treatment is to put you on
antidepressants and therapy or one or
the other or both right so I asked the
guys at Stanford I said you want to
study it well what what are the meta
studies you you have multiple studies
they give you the averages and they said
well the meta studies show that 60% of
the people who take Ender pressence and
now they know SSR ouris don't even work
there was a cover
a year ago in September know this nobody
email me I've been taking 17 years oh
really yeah I don't go look at sep
September of 2022 cover of Newsweek says
meta studies show the ssris don't work
but we keep selling them right yeah well
then what am I doing but watch this
here's the stats 60% don't improve at
all 40% of people improve the average
Improvement according to meta studies is
50% so they're half as depressed as they
were now some people get well but it's a
very small percentage so I said you
could almost do that with a placebo and
the guy laughed and said yeah I said
what's the best study you've ever done
the most effective study in science they
said there was a study done at John's
Hopkins about five and a half five years
ago paron me and who who what did the
this is from Stanford that who John's
Hopkins John's Hopkins Hospital has some
of the best researchers and so forth and
so they did this study and here's what
they did they gave people psilocybin for
a month magic mushrooms and cognitive
therapy I said well you ought to get
some change out of that he goes yeah it
was the greatest change they've ever
seen in the history of Psychiatry 6
weeks after treatment 53% excuse me 54%
of the people had no symptoms of
depression dude I have I take four stems
in a Diet Coke I'll talk to my sister
for an hour you know so I fully support
that sir but unfortunately so you're
saying there's there's new methods
there's new methods but but I said okay
that's amazing but I said I think we'll
do better but let's see so they did a
group they modeled that same drug study
did the same same thing with me with no
drugs I put people in this six day
seminar I have called Date With Destiny
and they picked all the people and put
them all CL annual seminar right yeah
one year and what was amazing was the
results were so profound that they
didn't want to get cancelled so they
sent the data blind out to three other
organizations before they published it
and they published in the Journal of
Psychiatry last year results 6 weeks
later with no drugs just six days of
rewiring your brain 100% of the people
no depression whatsoever even better
177% of the people had suicidal ideation
no suicide adiation here's what the best
part 11 months later they followed up
72% reduction in negative emotions still
no depression 52% Improvement in
positive emotions so when you make a
shift in a way you use your brain and it
gets conditioned and it does get
conditioned so they they were studying
how it works and so there's a
biochemical change that actually happens
in the body perspective that's the thing
it's like yeah you got to change like
yeah instead of just being like I want
to have this New Year's resolution
another rule for myself I need to change
the ruler that's you got it you got it's
like I need to that's what I need to
change but a lot of people times we
don't even see that we're the ruler yeah
you great a great metaphor this episode
is sponsored by prize piics do you love
firing on different sports well prize
picks is the best daily fantasy sports
app for you that's right you can fire on
all your favorite sports from the
NHL
NBA
NFL us UFC and more instead of choosing
teams you choose individual players
that's what I like about prize picks
it's novel it is it has a unquity to it
you get to you get to choose a player so
you could say Brock pie gonna do two
touchdowns you and you pick more or less
and that's how you pick them you could
say uh Jordan Matthews going to have
five receptions more or less and that's
how you would pick them download the app
and use code Theo prize pick will match
your deposit up to
$100 that's right prize picks thank you
for your support blue chw oh man
somebody's allergic to this good wiener
huh well what I'm telling you is
bluechew is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra CIS and Levitra but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
the best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in a line
at the pharmacy I hate that you have to
lie to people they're like what are you
getting and you're like oh God I'm sick
I'm in a wheelchair and they're like
you're not in a wheelchair and you're
like you're right I'm waiting waiting
for that Wier dope baby you feel me blue
bluechew wants to help you have better
sex discover your options at bluechew
chew it and do it and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try blue
chew free when you use our promo code
Theo at the checkout just pay $5
shipping that's
blue.com promo code Theo to receive your
first month free visit BL
cw.com for more details and important
safety information and we thank blue Chu
for sponsoring the podcast that's a
great a great metaphor you know you know
like if you wanted to go go do a I don't
know if you're into racing at all but
like a Lon a 24-hour race or Baja 1000
you could have a amazing car Ferrari
it's not going to last you have to
re-engineer that car to be able to take
on the desert or drive for 24 hours or
go to the ones that are in the desert
there where they have a pipe so that
when you go down it still can get the
air to the combustion of the engine we
have to re-engineer ourselves so the
times we in we're in a time right now it
feels like winter where there's more
fear than usual yeah it's a season it'll
pass do you think that's true I know
it's true you study history think of it
this way there's patterns because
because we see a lot of stuff right like
there's so much things going on it's
like you know there's all kind yeah like
we all it feels like that's true but
because it's constantly fed to you it's
hard for me to know if it's true or if
it's just well it may be true but it's
disproportionate it's like you didn't
know 30 years ago there was an aircraft
crash in some third four third world
country but now you know in 10 seconds
in your pocket so you know when people
over react to something you've ever
gotten pissed off over something little
the reason you overreact is it's not
that moment it's that it happened again
right did it again right so I call that
stacking so when you stack problem on
problem on problem pretty soon your
whole biochemistry it's hard to get back
but you can also stack the good that's
why I do the morning priming so when you
stack a good thing on top of a good
thing on top of a good thing your whole
biochemistry changes and now you see the
world through different eyes it's not
like you're guaranteed to succeed but
you're probabilities of pulling it off
and enjoying yourself are up about a
th000 f oh yeah and like I'll go to I go
to like AA meetings I go to recovery
meetings right so um and I notice if I
go to a couple in a day dude by Friday
I'm a good
guy you know I'm like hugging people I'm
like telling blind people I'm going to
heal them I can't but I'll do this for
like 30 seconds on them you know it's
like you just feel like but you're right
it's but it takes me I have to stack
them up and it's like and then it's
usually a couple days later that I even
I'm like man why do I feel so great it's
like oh because I did this work over the
past 10 days you know and what you did
there were actually when you really do
it strongly like that it creates a
biochemical change and that creates a
new habit in your nervous system so what
notice is that your in your body like
your your your Chemistry in your body
actually notices you're doing something
different and want to here's what here's
what they found they they did my work
with a top Professor who's highly rated
at Stanford he did my work word for word
but he didn't do what I do in event
which is change your biochemistry change
the way you move your breathe your voice
all those things change you he didn't do
that he just taught it he got
unbelievable results he's a tremendous
teacher and Professor but mine were 300%
greater because the biochemical change
so they followed me for three years had
me wear the $68,000 device that measures
heart rate variability they come during
every break and take my saliva they took
my blood do my blood
pressure it was crazy but they did it on
several events over three years and they
found all these Wild Things like and is
Stanford did it yeah Stanford did and
what they found was at the same group
they Stanford in partnership with a
group that's working like Tom Brady and
some of the greatest athletes and they
have this thing they called the um uh
Championship biochemistry and so if Tom
Brady is down in the fourth quarter by
10 points and it's a Super Bowl how does
that guy come back and win the reason is
because there's a part of him that goes
in this state and I do it every time I
get on stage but my audience does it as
well and they measure it so what happens
is testosterone explodes through my body
that gives you incred drive and push and
I've got to keep this building going
imagine you know 10,000 15 20,000 people
I got to reach the guy at the back for
12 straight hours the level of intensity
is amazing playfulness fun but it's
still intensity but normally that has a
lot of stress with it my cortisol which
is the stress hormone drops through the
floor same as Tom so what you get is
total drive doesn't guarantee success
but total drive and not a lot of stress
so you're able to stay centered and go
so my audience though this amazing thing
the so they measurement they found it
like you know I jump a thousand times in
a day on stage and I weigh 290 lbs so
every time I jump and come down it's
four times your body weight so I'm
imagine a th000 pounds of pressure a
thousand times in a day so my bone
density is you look at I look like a
gorilla underneath it I've done I've
done it for like 40 years right so on
the other hand they also saw that you
know if you're running with somebody and
you can't talk any longer you've gotten
to a four of lactic acid I'm in an 18
and still speaking so then they started
testing my audiences and they saw it
looks like music when I go into these
states the audience follows me and they
measured it then when Co happened I had
all people at home and so we had people
in 195 countries so they went to people
in 40 countries and measured them in
real time as we're doing this now
imagine at a live they're measuring them
over yeah I built this what happened was
not zoom but like a larger scale Zoom
yeah 20 foot high LED screens 67 highest
resolution I built a piece so I can
bring people up Eric Yan from Zoom he
built the system so instead of th000
people I could do 25,000 I've done a
million and a half people in one seminar
to give me an idea for 4 days it's been
wild so but when I built this I wanted
to figure out help people and I was like
could it really work through these
screens it was just out of necessity
because every stadium was closed the
governor of California calls me and says
March of 2020 we're about to have an
event for 12,500 people and he goes you
can only put 100 people in the stadium
like what are you talking about right
it's not going to work so I was like
screw you we'll move to Vegas they'll
never shut down Vegas they shut down
Vegas like 10 days before we move 12 500
people there then I went we'll go to
Texas the governor there told me he'll
never been he he he bent right yeah
we'll do it in Joe Rogan's yard we did
it in movie theaters for allow you put
10 people and we did 1250 movie theaters
they shut down the movie theaters so I
built the studio so they came and
measured the people in all these
different countries and what's Wild is
like we start here at 10:00 a.m. for
like a 4-day seminar and I had like I
just did one for you know 14,000 people
and we had about a couple thousand
people from Australia we're starting at
10: a.m. it's midnight for them I go 12
to 13 hours so they go from Midnight to
1: in the afternoon for four straight
days and nights and we lost 1% of the
people good day good night so so they
have but their biochemistry is changing
the same as mine and so that's why a
year later the changes are still there
without them ever interacting with me
again because people will this last well
that's why Stanford did the study so
that's what the study is so you saying
so when the when the study you were
talking about a little bit ago that was
they went back to people that had gone
to your seminar that's correct and they
uh and they measured them in a year
later you said 50 something per of them
still had no reduction of 72% negative
emotions increase of positive emotions
52% but now you know people uh since
covid we got so used to being home
people like why should I have to go to
work I don't want to drive to work and
people at offices want people to come to
work there's all these conflicts right
there's a lot more people being able to
work at home but now if you read the
studies people are more unhappy now than
they were at the peak of covid because
they wanted to be at home but now they
feel isolated yeah you know and so what
they don't understand is the path of
least resistance never makes you happy
it's like it do you have to push
yourself when people talk about
self-esteem I hate this term like so
many kids were taught to get a
participation trophy for something and
they thought I'm going to build their
self-esteem this way people can tell
your whole life you're a piece of crap
and your brain can goes screw you I'll
show you and you become somebody people
your whole life can tell you you're
beautiful you're perfect you're the best
and you can still not believe them be
depressed about your life and think
you're nobody your life self-esteem your
self-esteem esteem for yourself is
earned by you doing something difficult
for you when you do something that's
incredibly hard and you push through it
your brain starts to have inner Pride
not fake ego Pride right so you're
saying none of that other so so that
outside of stuff doesn't really matter
your self-esteem is truly based on your
relationship with yourself yes and your
ability to grow I mean what makes people
happy progress if you get some Big Goal
you want Che a lot of them in your life
right there's one of two responses when
you achieve the goal the horrible one is
is this all the is which a lot of people
do after fighting for a goal and this
all there is oh yeah but the but the
other one is let's say oh this is
amazing how long does that amazing
feeling of achieving your goal last six
years a year 6 months 6 days 6 hours
what would you say um the actual it for
me it doesn't last really long I don't
feel that kind of stuff very much yeah
well also you'd be numbed by those drugs
right but for most people it's somewhere
between six hours and probably six weeks
right so not super long no and so the
purpose of life is not just to get your
goals your goals or you're getting what
you want doesn't make you happy what
makes you happy is who you become in
pursuit of those goals so the growth the
progress even if you don't achieve it
yet but you start losing weight or you
start building muscle or you start
making your relationship better or you
start to build a business the building
the progress is what makes you feel
alive because we're all made to either
grow or die if your relationship's not
growing it's dying if your business is
not growing it's dying there's no in
between that doesn't work so
and when you grow you have something to
give and what makes people fulfilled is
growing and giving sharing it with
somebody because there's only so much
joy you can have by yourself drugs
alcohol Entertainment sex with yourself
whatever by yourself there's a limit to
what you can feel that's why whenever
something great happens most of us want
to tell someone share with somebody we
love because when you share it it
magnifies it so that's really what we
were trying to show people is how to
create that kind of progress and a
problem in New Year's is as you said a
resolution is just like what do I want
and they don't think about in any depth
they say it and then here's the problem
yeah they don't take it beyond that they
have no plan right or it's a very simple
plan and by February 1 by the first of
February 95% of those things are already
broken but what they're really is put my
years resol loing in
December you know well you need a path
and so if you want to make your
relationship better your business better
your life better it starts with knowing
what you want you got say what do I want
why do I want it and what kind of person
would I have to be to have that stay and
then you got to a second step where you
got to tell yourself find and tell
yourself the truth truth which is
there's a gap between where I am and
where I want to be and don't
yourself don't go I'm I'm a little
overweight or I'm fat cuz I'm big boned
no you're fat cuz you have poor habits
right that's how it works yeah some
people yeah I remember this the people
always like he'll grow out of it and I'm
like dude he's 34 like my buddy's
Grandma's like it's just baby fat he'll
grow out of it it's like we all have
different but it's like he ain't
you know Ronnie ain't growing out the
reason you don't grow out of it is you
have to see what's causing you to have
that Gap and it's one them only a couple
things either you got fear so you're not
taking action or you might have for
example uh some limiting beliefs like it
never works I've tried everything the
good ones are gone so you don't even
begin or you might have some emotion
gets in the way or a bad habit or maybe
you're just missing the skill like no
one's ever taught you how to make money
or grow a business or have a great
relationship so you're learning on the
job and it's painful to learn the job so
I've always said find somebody who's
extraordinary at something or many
people figure out what they're doing and
do that it's called modeling instead of
Reinventing the wheel now you can add
yourself to it yeah but modeling gives
you the pathway to power and then once
you know what you want why you want it
you're honest about the Gap you come up
with a quick plan not a perfect one and
you start taking action and then you
face your demons you slay your dragons
what needs to change like okay I'm never
going to have a relationship if I'm numb
all the time so I got to I got to change
this it's hard but I'm I'm going to do
the hard thing right and when you do the
hard thing you get momentum and then
what was hard becomes easy after a while
and that's the secret dang gosh I'm
going need a calculator to even go
through that again
but but that's okay you know but it's a
lot of great information you know I'm
talking I talk rly because I'm so
passionate but you know you take people
through at an event where they get to
process it and take time through it to
give you sense yeah no I appreciate it
man I feel like uh it's nice you to
share that stuff with this because I
know it's stuff that you learned over
the years and you know and it's a lot of
value in that and that you even taken
that time to just share that kind of
stuff with us and I know you guys have a
program
it's uh not the DAT with Destiny but you
guys have another program that you guys
do oh yeah that that program started
with uh Co because when all the whole
world shut down I was like people need
this right now how do I help so I built
that studio I told you about and I was
like okay why don't I do where you don't
have to travel because they can't why
don't make it so there's no money
involved and let's just serve as many
people as we can and so I put together a
this three-day immersion of just three
hours a day not 12 and I said let's give
people an experience where they can
really transform the first year we had
half a million people do it last year we
had a million and a half people so we're
doing one more this year on on at the
same time all at the same time wow in
195 countries every country in the world
it's so fantastic so we're doing one
this year January 25th through the 27th
it's absolutely free there's no charge
not partially free um and all the people
have to do is they go to it's called
time to rise like it's time to change
your life right here time toise
summit.com yeah uh January 25th through
27th and it's free it's free for anybody
who wants to go and they can bring the
friends or family they can do it from
their house they don't have TR they go
to the office and do it with people
around them so it's really amazing the
results we have had people change their
business change relationship get off
drugs I tell you one fun example though
two years ago there's this guy that was
735 PBS he never would have made it to a
seminar he saw was free he's been in bed
he his brother died he got addicted to
painkillers oh yeah and then his body
just blew up and then he now had they
told him he have to be on an oan mask
the rest of his life he couldn't get out
of bed a CPAP machine you mean yeah well
it wasn't CPAP it's pure ongoing oxygen
oh that's nice yeah and then secondly he
couldn't get out of bed to go to the
bathroom he had to be in bed he was
naked in bed for 5 years and 730 lbs so
he watches and I brought him up on
screen I didn't know he was there he
raised his hand vially so I raised up
and I ask him questions so he got so
inspired by this he took this little
like like clothes hanger bar and just
started doing these little exercises and
over 90 days I I told him I said you get
out of that bed make it to the restroom
you get out of the restroom and drive a
car again which I had done in seven
years I haven't been a been in seven
years and I said I'll fly you to my
Unleash the Power Within event for 4
days you'll walk on fire with me and
you'll really shift your life right he's
lost 320 lbs he 3 months late was out of
the out of the bed for the first time he
drove a car he fell in love with this
girl he came to the event walked on fire
and now he's like in our we have a
network of people because once you come
to this event there's people all over
the world you become friends with and
he's like the Superstar of all these
people cuz they can't believe the
changes he's made and it all happened
because he never would have come to an
event but because he could do it from
home in his bed he could do that it
could reach him wow yeah what's
something like I notic like there's been
times in my past where it's like I think
I didn't want to change because I wanted
to keep having an excuse right like I
remember even with smoking I remember it
was like um part of me didn't want to
stop there was a part of me I realized
it didn't want to stop smoking because I
knew if I stopped I wouldn't and it
wasn't like a it was kind of a
subconscious part of me but I knew if I
I stopped I would I wouldn't have
something to blame my inefficiency on or
my what I just wouldn't have something
to blame it's like it gave me something
to blame does that make any sense it
does because everything we do even
things that seem stupid or derogatory we
do to meet some needs and there's only
six needs people have we have a need for
Comfort or certainty we have a need for
variety we have a need to fill
significant unique special important
everybody has that need we have a need
to feel connection and love we have a
need to grow we have a need to
contribute Beyond ourselves it was just
Comfort I think yeah it's the comfort
and the certainty what you know but
there is a fear that everybody has two
fears all human beings at some moment
feel that they're not enough and to feel
like you're not enough for someone who
love you crave makes a person crazy
inside for someone who's what I didn't
hear that right somebody whose's love
you crave the average person you don't
care but if it's somebody who's love you
really want oh yeah so if you feel like
you're not enough then you feel like you
won't be loved to be worthless and
unloved is like psychological death so
people drug themselves eat they do
anything not to feel that well what are
your choices on changing that well you
could take on a new project build a
podcast build a business do something
but you have to take risks to do that
and risks you could look like a failure
you could fail which might look like
you're worthless might look like you're
not worthy of love so subconsciously we
come up with these ways to adapt so
smoking a cigarette comforts you because
when you take that big slow breath in
and blow it out nice and slow it changes
the tempo in your body completely you go
from stress to comfort you can do that
same without the cigarette but but
once you're addicted and it becomes the
go-to some people stop smoking and then
they overeat overeating puts all the
blood in your stomach and you start to
breathe slowly again and feel things and
you let go so you can get certainty and
comfort by those ways or you can do it
by working out and developing the sense
of strength that makes you certain or
you can do the same thing day after day
there's so many ways there's positive
ways and negative ways but we also need
uncertainty we need variety if you if
every day you know what's going to
happen how it's going to happen you get
bored out of your mind but if you have
so much variety you don't know what's
going to happen people freak out so
these needs bounce up against each other
and so when people do a behavior like
smoking smoking will give you comfort
certainty smoking will give you in some
people's case variety because you were
stressed out now you change your state
that feels different it's called variety
smoking will give you significance if
you think it's cool although today it's
a little harder to do that cuz most
people think you're an idiot we put you
in a separate room by yourself yeah they
think you are yeah so but it used to be
I'm cool if I smoke and some people say
you can't make me not smoke I'm
significant right for some people it's a
way to connect with other people who
smoke right so when you meet one of
those needs you like it when you meet
two you really like when you meet three
you get addicted and you get addicted to
positive things you get addicted to
exercise you get addicted to working out
you get addicted to you know growing
your business you everyone gets addicted
to something if it meets a bunch of your
needs it's amazing and in a
relationship if a person is certain that
you love them and there's always a
surprise they oh I I know they love me
and we have so many surprises we have so
much Variety in our life and I feel like
the most important person significant
and I feel so much love to them and
we're growing contributing I'm leaving
nobody says that because when your needs
are met people stay like whenever I work
with couples I work with hundreds of
thousands of couples over the years and
they always say one of them always say I
gave him or her everything everything
except what they needed if you gave them
what they needed they wouldn't be
leaving do you think we're afraid
sometimes to say what we need though too
or do you think we even know what we
need sometimes most people don't you're
absolutely right most people not only
don't say it but most people don't even
know it they're not even honest with
themselves yet right and how do we get
that because it almost seems like you're
just wandering around in the dark if you
don't even
know that they there's wiring in the
walls you know kind of well there's a
there's a part of your brain called the
reticular activating system big words
that scientists usually call it the RAS
it determines what you notice so there
are millions of things you could focus
on Even In This Moment the blood rushing
through your ear the heartbeat your
clothing touching your skin but you're
not thinking about all that right you
delete all that you focus on a small
number of things the Rees notice is what
you are going to focus on so if you get
clear on what you want you just say okay
and by the way when you say relationship
you I don't know what I want I go great
describe the relationship from hell what
do you don't want tell me everything you
I don't want a person like this I don't
want to be like that I don't want to be
and that creates energy when they're
done with a whole list then I go right
the opposite and you have the
relationship from heaven or I don't know
what I want in a career job right
everything you don't want who do you not
want to work with what kind of work you
not want to do people get their energy
going with that they're okay right the
opposite you got the job from heaven so
once you know what it is that you really
really want now all you got to do is
figure out okay what's gotten in the way
what what do I need to shift how can I
meet my needs in a better way but that's
why we do events like this because
telling people just go do that in their
normal environment is difficult but when
you go into Total Focus it's like I
started to say earlier if you if you
want to learn language and you went to
high did you did you take a language
foreign language in high school Spanish
one and Spanish I think
2,000 I don't know what it was and do
you speak Spanish well now no our guy
didn't even speak our guy was like he
got busted for fraud or something but uh
I don't know what we learned yeah but I
was in there for I was in there yeah I
was in there but the reason you don't
recall it was because it was a little
bit at a time and the brain doesn't
learn that way the brain learns best by
immersion if I said you have the money
and the time I'm not going to teach you
Italian I'm going to drop you in Rome
and I'm going to pick you up in 90 days
with no teacher oh yeah days later
you're speaking Italian because you're
in it 24 hours days seeing it feeling
experiencing it that's how I teach
that's why I do 12 hours for four days
that's why it's yeah that's why it's
it's an intense thing or it's a
immersion yeah and that's why it lasts
that's why it lasts ah wow man yeah it's
pretty impr it's um I think it's just
neat to see that even just using your
like seminar as an example that um that
it
takes immersion it takes real some some
real commitment I mean even if people
are coming for 6 days or even if people
are are going to show up for long days
on Zoom for four days in a row it's like
whatever it is it takes some real
commitment from ourselves to be able to
do those things so I get a lot of people
that get dragged there by somebody and
they're like oh I'm going to get out
here at the first break and you I
remember I had a friend of mine who's
now A friend of mine he wasn't before
but he came with a a client friend of
mine who was an NFL player this guy's a
billionaire and he sat down and he saw
people clapping and moving and stuff
because we move the body it's not a Rah
session it's the change of biochemistry
there's a science behind it right goes
I'm not going to do this I'm a
billionaire I don't do this crap right
and like 30 minutes later he's jumping
he's this is the greatest experience of
my life you know so sometimes you have
to get in the experience to know what it
is and then when you're in it and it's
so enjoyable because change doesn't have
to be painful it can be enjoyable but if
you don't know what to do and you just
do a little bit at a time pretty hard to
get a real change but when you go for
full immersion that's what happens but
you know I still write books and do
audios and things like that because you
need immersion and then you need some
space repetition you need feed the m in
a regular basis so I like have three
things I go I want to feed my mind every
day I'm need to read hear an audio for
20 30 minutes so I'm constantly growing
in some way I want to do imersion even I
do this two three times a year I'll go
places harder to do now because of who I
am but I'll go to the back of the room
I'll get somebody one-on-one to coach me
about something I did this brain
training for example it was like four
days and nights to put all these
electrodes on your brain to teach you
how to go on what's called Alpha Brain
the part of your brain where happiness
is a lot easier right so I remember it
was like 12 hours a day it was freezing
cold you this dark room and you you hear
these sounds based on your brain's
working you how to retrain your brain it
was hell and I'm like who do I got to
kill to get out of this oh me I'm the
one to put myself in this thing but at
the end of four days Castro it sound
like you were in qu it felt kind of like
that but after four days didn't you
entertain in qu I read that you didn't
did some show I did did some shows and I
heard that that was really cool of you
to do that it was crazy I can't believe
that tell me about that well I'll tell
you about it so first of all they have a
golf course down there which I didn't
even think you don't think like cuz
they're in the they're it's a tropical
area right so these people they're down
there it's a beautiful area so you go
down um I remember the flight we went on
to go down there you they have you have
to fly in like this crazy pattern I
guess in case like somebody's shooting
at you like you have to be able to evade
it so you go in this crazy shape and
then you see like out of the darkness
there's just like this it looks like a
big diamond ring like lit up just all
the the outlines of the whole base you
know and so we went there there's all
these big lizards not a lot of ladies
bring your lady you know or something or
bring you know bring a buddy who's
willing to you know say he's a lady you
know but there's yeah cuz there's not I
think there was I think seven women down
there there's like 1100 soldiers down
there though seven women oh that's a
brutal
environment but they are look I'll tell
you this the first day you might be like
I don't think she's my type by the
fourth day you're like that that is damn
Hillary clone and you get to come home
yeah yeah yeah yeah well the four I mean
there's a wedding ring shop there and it
is I mean for the seven women they're
all just sit around like this yeah it
looks like that that collection you have
right there they're just but it is that
that part was pretty remarkable oh um
just uh the beaches they have down there
real beautiful you don't hear anything
about them though CU they're the ones on
the military base so did you go to
entertain the the soldiers the soldiers
yeah we got to see some of the troop
areas and we got to do like some
volleyball with some of the prisoners or
whatever but um some of the prisoners
they made them wear like
they couldn't even see while they're
doing the volleyball it was bizarre but
yeah we got to play volleyball you play
volleyball and you can't see that's yeah
that's a that's the rules they made for
him but uh yeah and that might be I
don't know be another form of torture
yeah it may be I don't know what the the
the ACT is or the law is but hopefully
they prevented yeah that shouldn't be
allowed it was semi fun I guess but it
was yeah but um what was it like yeah
that was amazing man just to be able to
be down there you know wild just to be
able to go do comedy there go and do the
brighten people's Spirits there it was
fun we got to do a bunch we got to go to
go to um uh a lot of the Ford operating
bases during like the not Kuwait but
maybe Iraq like after that yeah like um
Bahrain um so you're the modern day Bob
Hope with a little more color we went
out there dude I think it's they call me
Bobby hopeless I think but we still show
up you know dude I met a gal yeah one
time I mean I I got to make out with a
girl in a Blackhawk helicopter
the I've flown in one but I haven't made
out one look I've flown one I was a
helicopter pilot for quite a while look
you I mean neither me or her were that
handsome I'll say that um are you sure
it was a her dude who knows she
seven who whatever you got to do man
it's the troops you know awesome don't
ask don't
ask that's the old I think that's what
they're doing now um but no I reason I
mentioned that to you though is it was
worth it cuz the end those four days
I've rewired my brain to have a
different level of Happiness so you
believe this you you know this you've
done it so many times that that is the
key that's the thing it's like you
excluded out these other things of like
this is fool's gold this is fool's gold
this is fool's gold I've been through
plenty of fool's gold right that's how
you get to the good stuff right that's
what I'm saying but if you give up if
you give up because something's
most of it's but then you find
those gems that really work and we find
the gems work then you use them for the
rest of your life and then you share
them with other people because you can
see it really works you know and then
you know then you the science behind it
but in the past I've just got people the
results who that is the science right
but it's nice now to have science
justifying or being able to show people
how powerful it is how effective it is
but you know it was in the Journal of
Psychiatry last year and all the people
thought this is going to spread like
crazy not one phone call because they're
still selling ssris right so I mean the
same people come to me they've always
come to me but but nobody from the
psychological community on major scale
and they just a big conference and
shared the results again and people were
fascinated and this has came up ask
questions but there's too much money in
the in the I know it's just even money
it's just habits this is how they do
their their business it's a business
right for those people so what do you
say to somebody like me then or I mean
sorry I'm sitting here so also me but um
yeah like who's CU there's ways like I
know once I right when I weaned off of
my medicine right I got to talked I
actually didn't talk to my doctor but
I've gotten off so many times over the
years I felt like I knew what I was
doing I did let my close friends know
hey I'm I'm getting off my medicine let
me know if anything what using at the
time just uh Lexa I've been taken right
I said let me know if anything seems
strange or whatever you know but then I
more strange than usual
yeah yeah yeah dude if I'm just like
masturbating at the house dude yeah
that's natural that's normal dude yeah
that's normal behavior right but if I'm
Pet
shopping you know that's a then you need
to call somebody you know you can
certain call somebody I'm looking at a
dog that's really scary D can you fetch
oh yeah it's getting weird um but what
I'm saying is uh yeah so there but I
started running right I knew I said
great my biggest thing is I don't want
to lose this bad this this opportunity
to see how I'm feeling because I'm not
doing my part of taking care of myself
you I have so much respect for you doing
that it's so hard to do but you did the
right thing which is what I teach you
got to replace it with something you
don't stop doing something you replace
something else but what you're replacing
it with actually changes your
biochemistry yeah I don't want to run
now I'm starting to freaking like it
dude I met somebody yesterday and we got
some damn Brook shoes
together well that's a good first step
yeah literally you're right but you get
the runners high and it's it's a good
high for you and you're making so it's
like it's not about stopping what you're
doing it's about starting something else
that's more fulfilling like running what
needs does it meet does it make you feel
comfortable afterwards you feel certain
you're going to feel good when you run
100% you have variety when you run is
like a totally different state yeah
sometimes I'll go around the track this
way some go around the track this way
okay okay and do you have sense of
significance like I'm really
changing I'm imp improving I'm becoming
more some guy the other day like this
kind of tough guy was like man you've
been out there for a while that's cool
you feel good yeah and do you feel more
connected to yourself or God when you're
running or the universe or nature or
anything like that yeah I feel like I'm
able to have some or like my brain will
have conversations that maybe I've been
meaning to have or whatever they just
kind of show up while I'm running and do
you feel like you're growing by doing
this running by getting better um yeah I
feel like it's not going to hurt me
that's for sure yeah you know and there
may be some form of contribution that'll
come out of it because because you feel
so much better you'll be able to give
more so you're meeting at least four or
five of your needs by running yeah
versus the drugs made you feel certain
mhm did they make you feel variety um no
that was the biggest problem that was
boring any feelings that's dead did they
make you feel significant no no then
they make you feel
connected no no they make you feel like
you're
growing no contributing to
others no so it met one need but when
you get in the habit of it and you're
numb it's hard to shift so it's it the
only reason people shift is they hit a
threshold I'll give you the chemistry of
transformation you see how it works for
you okay like there's five elements that
when they're there people transform so
the first one that usually happens is
satiation satiation means there's
nothing wrong but you've been doing the
same thing over and over and over again
after a while if your favorite meal was
steak and lobster and you have it every
day three times a day there's going to
be a point where you go like there's
nothing wrong with steak and lobster but
man I'm satiated right and that makes
you look around what what might what
might do different but it doesn't
usually make you change it just opens
your mind to change then you need the
second element and that is
dissatisfaction now it's not just you're
doing it it's not as good now you're
doing it and it doesn't feel good and
you start to feel that in the
relationship side you like this I don't
I don't want to feel this way then
that's still not enough that makes you
look more for a change that's the second
piece of chemistry the third piece of
chemistry is now you hit a threshold
thresholds like you ever been in a
relationship like way too long you know
oh yes brother I'm sorry I want to
apologize too to a couple of women um
yeah I should have you knew it was wrong
you knew it wasn't serving them or
serving you but you stayed because it
was certain it was hard to change well
what if I'm alone afraid to say certain
things yeah but if you got to the point
where the way you stay is you go it'll
get better it was better in the past or
you jump to the Future and say it's
better but there's a day we hear
threshold you go it's been painful in
the past it's painful today it's going
to be painful forever I'm the F out of
here right that's when people start to
change when you hit a threshold you get
the fourth piece you get an insight and
the Insight is what's really true and
usually figure it out it's not my
partner it's not my job it's me what's
going on in me and you make a
distinction and that creates an opening
like there's a chance you to change your
life in that moment you had that when
you were here and you couldn't feel
anything with this girl you felt
dissatisfaction you eventually got to a
threshold and you finally said wait a
second these drugs are just making me
numb I got to do something and you had
to jump through the opening because you
didn't know was on the other side
there's uncertainty a lot of people go
through all that and they get to the
opening it only stays open for a few
moments if you don't do something with
the Insight it closes you start all over
again you got to go through all the time
period of getting satiated and getting
dissatisfied again hitting a threshold
and some people just never jump through
the hole so I used to kick people
through the opening you know yeah I've
seen a couple videos you done like whoa
so but now but now what I do more is I I
bring them the opening over and over get
them to jump through so they get muscle
cuz otherwise it might last a year or
two but it's not going to last forever
if you do it you got a chance to it
lasting for a long time but you went
through that chemistry but very few
people do yeah you got dissatisfied
enough I'm thinking of some comedy Duos
who have gotten it done over the years
um Key and Peele come to mind Fay and
polar um Gillis and mccusker of course
and what about the perfect Duo when it
comes to Growing your business that's
you you and
Shopify
Shopify is the global Commerce platform
that helps you sell at every stage of
your business from the launchy own shop
stage to the first real life store stage
all the way to the did we just hit a
million orders stage Shopify is there to
help you grow you know I remember uh
when we first started selling uh podcast
merchandise we were just selling stuff
out of my apartment and then it got to
the point where we needed help and
Shopify does it right now you can sign
up for a $1 per month trial period at
shopify.com
Theo all lowercase go to shopify.com
tho now to grow your business no matter
what stage you're in shopify.com
SLO is pornography causing a problem in
your life that's a good question it's a
real question it has in mind it has at
certain periods in my life uh watching
porno and everything and watching porno
was making me it was ruining my life it
was ruining my life man May me feel just
so much shame that's what it did well
watching pornography has become
commonplace today and often times men
will use porno to numb the pain of
loneliness boredom anxiety and
depression
that's why I want to introduce you to my
friend Stephen Walt Steve is the founder
of Valor recovery he is a dear friend of
mine he is a dear friend of mine and
Valor recovery is a program to help men
overcome porn abuse and sexual
compulsivity that's right their coaches
are in long-term recovery and they will
be your partner mentor and spiritual
guide to transcend problematic behaviors
there is zero Commitment if if you reach
out to them it's just the first step and
trying to figure out if you may need
some help if you can get some help to
learn more about Valor recovery please
visit them at Valor recovery
coaching.com or email them at
admin Valor recovery
coaching.com the links will be uh on the
YouTube and again there's no commit when
you commitment when you reach out to
them um but I promise you uh only
something positive will come uh from you
reaching out and figuring out if um if
what type of help if any uh could
benefit you thank you are you struggling
with keeping your website up to date and
running your business well a lot of
people are and now you can binge all the
web design and digital marketing you
want with
modify that's right we use modify they
run our website modify helps you with
unlimited web design and redesigns
unlimited website updates 247 support
and digital advertising if you always
wonder well how do I advertise and how
do I get people to know about my
business online modify can do it plus
you'll get a designated designer
consider updating your existing website
and getting a new one visit modify
oy.com Theo for 50%
off the last website you'll ever need
again visit modify
oy.com
EO for 50% off the last website you'll
ever need um one thing that I think
keeps a lot of people from progressing
in life and stuff uh is like shame you
know how is how is
shame it's almost hard to find first of
all people can say you're ashamed of
yourself and I could I could say that
yeah I'm ashamed of myself but it's
really a feeling you have to really and
it's so like it's like a it's like a
it's so vague kind of if that makes any
sense but it feels like like one of the
biggest sicknesses of our being it it
shame is one of the most negative
emotions because what it does is it
shrinks everything in you and it puts
you in such a Negative state that your
energy drops so think of this way where
your energy is really low you do very
little to change things everything seems
impossible you don't respond to other
people the same level when you're super
high energy you've done whatever it
takes you're either excited about your
future or you're present or you're
working on yourself or you're working
out like running and you're that high
energy same problem happen you can laugh
at it crack a joke at it and it's easy
right so your energy level with certain
emotions increase and other emotions
goes through the floor and when you beat
yourself up or you have shame or
anything like that your energy goes down
and then it's even harder to change
which then creates more shame see I said
I was going to change I didn't change
what's
what's wrong with me why can't I do this
and then you start building up a story
that it's something wrong with you and
what I try to explain to people there's
nothing wrong with you you're not broken
you don't need to be fixed I'm not here
to be your Guru what you need is there's
some patterns some habits in the way you
use your mind and your body if we change
those habits you'll have a different
experience that's all it is but being
ashamed will keep you away from that
because it'll put the energy so
negatively in your body and you're so
wiped out that it's like it's impossible
right and then when you're in shame you
come up all all these negative beliefs
about yourself and once you believe
something whether do you believe it's
true you believe it not is true because
what when you believe something's true
you'll find evidence for it yeah like
I'll give you a little test look around
this room right now and notice
everything you can see that's brown okay
everything you can find it's a test look
all around both sides of you anything
you see that's brown people at home look
at that in your own room what you see is
brown okay close your eyes okay tell me
everything you just saw that was
red now obviously you saw a lot more
Brown didn't you yeah why cuz you're
looking for it open your eyes Now look
for red look for red anywhere you can
find red any place you can find red okay
okay did you find more red this time how
come because I was looking for red
that's right once you develop a belief
you find what supports it so watch this
you will find stuff that's not even
there in order to be successful I bet
you saw some big called it brown
just to feel successful did you right
over there I bet you saw some things
burgundy and called in bread just so you
can feel successful I factored in some
of those uh now and later you see what
I'm saying if you think you're you're
screwed up you're messed up you're going
to find and you're going to color
yourself that way if you think someone
else is a jerk you're G if you think
they're your friend and they have a bad
day they bad behavior you all they're
having a bad day if you think they a bad
person then it's always going to be that
way what was the first part you said of
that if you think whether you think it's
true whether you think it's not it's
going to be true for you in other words
whatever you believe is self-evident you
reinforce what you believe you found
what you were looking for so you got to
train yourself to look for something
different that's why I do priming and
that's why I do immersion cuz after four
or five days of thinking differently
seeing differently focusing differently
different beliefs you have a different
life Yeah a different experience but if
you do it for a few minutes you know
kind of hard to do so that's why I still
do events because immersion has so much
power but some people do it through an
audio they listen to like an audio 30
minutes a day every day and they develop
a new set of habits or they do it by
exercising or they do reading a book and
then they use it right away so there's
lots of ways to get there but immersion
is the fastest way it is yeah and you
and that's the fastest method and you
use it for yourself too of course yeah
it's like going to that class why why am
I still doing that it's like cuz you got
to keep growing and every time you make
a new insight it stacks on all the other
good things you can stack the negative
and be overwhelmed or you can stack the
positive and feel this tremendous sense
of momentum and that's the other secret
momentum you're getting momentum right
now it sounds like momentum is like
you've ever watched a team and they're
getting their butt kicked and then
somebody suddenly does something magical
they steal the ball they do something
and boom it creates a spark and then the
other team takes over right momentum
shifts everything and momentum comes by
doing the right thing over and over and
after a while it becomes what you expect
to do or another one is certainty you
know I work with a lot of great athletes
those rings are from all you know that's
from you know I own some teams like the
lafc football club and the Golden State
Warriors on a piece of them the Dodgers
on a piece of them but I've also coached
them all so those are all national
championship rings that I've got so I'm
really proud of those rings they're a
representation of what I was able to
build by working with these people but
when you look at the people that are the
best of the best
they have certainty if you see Steph
Curry you know us with the Warriors he
makes those three three-point shots I'm
almost half half court right he releases
the ball he doesn't wait to go through
he turns around and just like he already
knows it's in like how does he do that
he's a genius well true but where did
the genius come from he's been shooting
500 shots a day every single day seven
days a week for his entire adult life
and most of his teens now think about
that he's been in the NBA 15 years he's
the greatest three-point shooter in the
history of the world he made 3,360
something shots now three-point shots no
one even close watch
this 500 shots a day that's 14,000 shots
a month that's 168,000 shots a year
that's over 15 years just his
professional career a lot 2.52 million
shots he's taken in practice so that he
can make 3,300 and be the greatest in
history so people get rewarded in public
for what they practice in private yeah
um sometimes I have a tough time feeling
proud of myself do you know what that
you know and I think I've had other
people call in our our show that have
talked about that you know what do you
think it is I don't know I feel like um
I almost feel like there's just there's
a disconnect like it doesn't even land
on me or I feel like maybe if I feel
like I'm proud of myself like if I
actually feel proud of myself it'll go
against some script that I've always had
written or some
some thing that was always written
inside of me you know it's like it it's
almost like it wouldn't if I wrote on
the wall of myself I'm proud of you it
wouldn't even show up on the
wall what emotion would you feel if you
saw that um like what emotion would I
feel if I saw what I'm proud of myself
would you go would you say be
pissed off by it would you be annoyed
would you just I think I feel ashamed of
myself for even thinking it that's
interesting and It produced an emotion
in you just now even when you just
thought about it I saw that flash in
your eyes just a little bit of water
little bit
oh yeah dude we cry on here every
week sorry dud beautiful no it's okay
but yeah we don't have any we don't have
any Shame about that no you shouldn't
but I'm say liquid Le leaving your body
in a public place as long as Through
Your Eyes is not a problem that's what
I'm talking about huh yeah yeah don't
ask don't ask that's right but my point
is there's a real anchor for you there
so let me explain it to you everybody
has what I call an emotional home yeah
do you ever watch like um a place here
and let's say you know where the Cyclone
happens every 2 or 3 years and wipes out
everything or tornado comes through and
you see these poor people all their
stuff's all over the ground and they're
picking it up and you could have a Heart
of Stone not to feel they rebuild two
years again it happens again two years
later happens again some part of you
eventually goes why don't you move you
know it's like why don't you move a lot
of Vietnam's like that it floods New
Orleans is like that it floods New
Orleans like that so here's why don't
they move because it's home it's what
they know we have an emotional home we
have certain emotions that got built up
in your youth I had four fathers I had a
mother was pretty intense and I had a
lot of emotions that came out of that
experience if I didn't reprogram myself
I wouldn't be sitting here with you
today because my emotional home was not
good feelings it's what I was used to so
even though it didn't feel good you go
there because it's what you know yeah
it's comfortable so yeah it almost feel
like I was deserting myself if I felt
good about myself which is crazy I'd
almost feel like I was
leaving I don't know yeah it's almost
like I know those feelings finish that
thought I'm believing what well it's
almost like I feel like I know those
feelings of not not feeling good about
myself so well that I would be I don't
want to leave them alone because we
always had each other and it was like if
I leave
them you know if I have you ever have
you ever had a friend I leave them I
just I won't I don't know does that make
sense though yeah it does you won't what
if I leave them I'll just be letting
them down and they're not even yeah
they're not even real but they're to
part of me some part of me inside of me
I can't even access they're like his
brothers that's right that they're your
home brother and by the way I I I really
appreciate you being so vulnerable
because people watching there seeing
that allow them to be vulnerable because
you're a role model of that because
you're funny as but to be able to
be that vulnerable is beautiful but let
me just tell you
something those are not your friends
yeah you know and you're not going to
abandon those parts of yourself you're
going to find these other parts of
yourself that need to be in charge it's
not to say that you can't have negative
emotions or fears or feelings but the
ones that don't support you you got to
break that pattern and the way you break
the pattern first is you start to see
you get a new experience if I get you an
experience where you feel like you
actually felt proud of yourself without
those feelings and there was no sense of
loss and I did that with you for days
and days you'll never go back wow
because your brain will go what the f
I'm not going back to that
those weren't my friends it' be like you
know it's like having a friend that
beats the out of you every single
day and it's like I'm letting him down
if I don't let him beat the out of
me right it's like oh no I I got to beat
there for him cuz I got to be there so
he can beat the out of me on face
right that's pretty much what happen
here dude you're like Dam here we go
again and so then what happens though is
the reason you went for the
antidepressants is it's so overwhelming
that numbing at least feels a less I'd
rather see you cry and feel the pain
even I want you to feel pain as a
brother yeah no I'm grateful to feel it
I want it out of my system that's right
but the next step for you is drawing a
line on the sand of how you really want
to feel so I'll have people in the event
right down I give them like a minute I
go draw a line down the middle right
down the left side all the positive
emotions you feel in an average week not
once a year or not once a month the ones
you regularly feel whatever good
feelings the average emotions in a in a
positive week positive so what are some
ones you feel in a week in a week uh
feel at least at least once a week okay
any emotion uh positive start with the
positive positive em hopeful okay um
thankful yeah um loving yeah um
and uh maybe some pride good and so so
the pride the pride is sneaking in now
that's not ego Pride that's pride of
like you're growing well I'm learning
about Pride I mean it's like I said it's
really hard for me to feel proud of
myself you know so stop saying that okay
because every time you say that you're
rewiring it back into your body over and
over it's a story it's like there's an
old phrase that says tell a lie big
enough T like big enough loud enough and
long enough sooner or later people
believe it you know who said that Hitler
oh I think you going say fouchy well
same
difference but yeah I didn't know who
was going to be we're aligned on that
one brother you're a quicker thinker
than I am but no so yeah we hear what
we're saying but you the conversation
you've said with yourself you've done
how many times do you think you've said
that said what that you know I'm it's
hard for me I you know I say I say it a
lot yeah it's because I think I'm yeah
it's like having a new story for myself
I you know part of me is still there's a
heavy bit even to my whole new story
having a new story even having some
success in my life it's almost like some
of it feels embarrassing you know and
some people feel like you know the word
people use is impossible syndrome it's
all it's just fear that you're
not enough we all have that fear brother
I feel that at times I don't feel it
much now but I'm 63 years old and I've
done a shitload of things for 40 years
you know you buil enough pattern yeah I
built up new patterns it's like a muscle
you know everybody's got the muscle if
you use it it grows if you don't use it
you lose it right it doesn't ever
disappear though it just looks like it's
not there but if you demand it you push
it beyond what it's comfortable with and
that's what you're doing right now
you're pushing beyond your comfort you
were settling for Comfort to try to
survive
now you're like f that I want more out
of this life you know I'm not going to
settle for that but then you keep
telling yourself the old story so change
your story change your life it sounds
overly simplistic but it is true oh I
love it I appreciate you saying it yeah
yeah I think a lot of this chat has been
about that in but look at the positive
emotions you wrote down sir you just
told me verbally right so you're hopeful
you have are you playful or funny or
what would be your term around that part
of you cuz I didn't hear that part of
you I know it's there no I feel like
that part of me became such my work that
I haven't had as much free time to be
that as I like on your own okay cool
well so those are the positives what are
the negatives you feel in an average
week at least once a week not once a
month once a year what are the negative
emotions you feel um ugly okay um I feel
um incapable
angry um and I feel uh disappointing
okay so which which of those emotions is
most powerful for you uh the positive
list or the negative list
the negative list is more powerful
that's true for most people watch this
what's an emotion that if it became the
dominant emotion in your life one or two
it would get rid of those negas like
they would have any power over
you what would be an emotional state
would it be like courage or would it be
playfulness or would it be uh uh let's
say Joy or would it be grat you've
already got gratitude more gratitude
what be an emotion that's so strong that
it would get rid of the disappointment
probably love you know there you go
that's your core brother I didn't hear
you say that on the first one that's all
you really want it's probably why you do
this podcast it's probably why you make
people laugh me too by the way only
reason I do what I do is I love people
and I love to see people happy because I
was so unhappy myself and I got out of
it so I was so grateful it's like I
don't it's like you know I feed you know
100 million people a year 100 million
meals doing I've done a billion meals in
the last eight years Christ dude that's
almost that's what that's what
McDonald's did isn't it and it was free
they're pretty cheap at McDonald's but
dang dude dud but I did it not because
I'm a good person I did it because I
grew up and I had no money and no food
when I was 11 somebody came and fed us
on Thanksgiving and I was like that made
me believe strangers care strangers care
about me and they care about strangers
and so I fell in love with people and I
want to make people feel happy and I
know what it feels like not food I know
what it feels like to be absolutely
depressed and miserable and saying do I
even need to stick around in this life
right so I don't want anybody else to
feel that so it drove me to find answers
not just for me once I found them for me
I wanted to help as many people as I can
why don't want to do it cuz I love love
cuz when you help people that much I
mean I have so much love my life it's
ridiculous I get stopped on the street
every day and people don't come up and
say oh I like your show or something
come up and go you changed my life oh my
God I love you Tony Robins and I always
say no I didn't do it you did it but I'm
glad I helped but I love the love that
comes from it yeah so we all really want
love but we're afraid we're not enough
and you my friend you are growing like a
weed right now cuz you're doing things
most people never get out of and I'm not
blowing smoke your way I'm not a
no I don't feel I don't feel
that man I appreciate you saying it yeah
truth but you got to you got to know
notice your progress and you got you got
to stack the good and then you got to
stop the old story and the minute you
start to say that phrase that's
an old story it's not true anymore yeah
I think a part of me is afraid that I'm
going to leave a part of me like um if I
you know if I even if I be successful so
let's investigate that for a second like
if I be successful I'm going to leave a
part of me behind you know well then
you're effed right now because you're
already
successful you got I don't know how many
millions of people I'm sure that watch
your podcast you make people laugh all
over the world people that embarrassed
sometimes but all those emotions are old
habits they're just habits so I
understand that and by the way when you
feel embarrassed or you feel these
negative emotions
yeah it also makes you feel for yourself
for a little bit so that's the other
part you might be afraid of like some
people take care of every well like for
some I don't know if this is you but
some people are so busy trying to make
everybody else happy all the time they
don't take care of themselves unless
it's a big ass problem and then for the
the first time even it's a negative
feeling at least I'm feeling for myself
I'm feeling for me and that might be
what you're afraid of losing let's try
it for a second here what if I told you
you could go back and feel like as
much as you want it'll never stop right
but you don't have to have it be the
predominant emotion of your
life that you this need to beat yourself
up or be ashamed or not be too happy
that it's an old story that got wired a
long time ago and it has nothing to do
with who you really are but when you
keep telling yourself it's like my
friend I need to take care of I'm going
lose a part of myself no you'll never
lose that part there's a part of me that
would be a victim very easily I was beat
as a child my mom was a beautiful woman
I'm not denigrating her when she put
when she put when she put alcohol
together with prescription drugs she was
crazy and I was 5'1 in high school
believe it or not I'm 67 now I told
people the difference I tell people the
difference is personal growth right but
I had a tumor in my brain that made me
grow but I was this little guy she would
slam my head against it she'd Put liquid
soap down my throat cuz she said I was
lying and I wasn't lying and when the
person you love most is trying to hurt
you you can do a number on your head but
I look back now and fortunately I didn't
let that stop me and I didn't settle for
that I struggled for a long time I look
back on I can honestly tell you if she
was the mother I'd hope she'd been like
if I was wellfed you really think I'd be
trying to feed a bill you a tri not a
billion people now I'm trying to feed
100 billion people you think I would be
spending my time doing that if I was a
wellfed kid I don't think so if she had
been the mother I want I wouldn't have
become the man I'm proud to be yeah so
those emotions are not you they were a
part of your past they were a pattern
it's a pattern of what you do with your
body and breathe but it meets some of
your needs to feel feel yourself or feel
sorry for yourself or feel sad right you
follow me it's like a self-pity thing a
little bit but what you're really
wanting is not self-pity you're wanting
self-love you just haven't learned how
to give it to yourself my way of doing
that is gratitude CU When you're
grateful love flows naturally is that a
common pattern that sometimes cuz I
noticed over like a about two years I
noticed that I one of my biggest
addictions sometimes was self-pity I
didn't even realize it I thought I was
helping myself by like focusing on
myself but really I'd been too I was
feeling too pitiful yeah I I didn't it
was it was man it was I realized my
alcohol was self-pity anytime I also
also alcohol is a depressant so what's
going to do is lower it feels good in
the moment but then it lowers your
energy and your blood sugar everything
right same for self-pity self-pity same
thing now your energy think about it
self-pity if you're in self-pity right
now 0 to 10 10 total high energy Zero's
no energy where are you in self-pity
where would you put it oh two yeah where
are you when you're feeling
excited um where's my energy 0 to 10
yeah uh my energy when I'm feeling
excited is like a nine yeah which one do
you want to be I'd rather be the nine
yeah why the wanton us just do that
I
know yeah I think but I think you said a
lot of it is pattern I think that's the
thing and a lot of people I think you
don't notice when you're in self-pity
man I had no clue like I was still
living a life and it was going well and
it was going but it was just just a lot
of times I was drinking my own self-pity
you know and and I don't feel like I do
it a lot now but there's times where I
can fall back into that so if you do
just like if you do it's like oh I'm
going to self-pity you don't beat
yourself up you just that old pattern I
don't do that anymore let's get out
and the best way to get out is go for
your run do something physical or shift
what you're doing or focus on doing
something for someone you love any of
those things will get you out of your
mind because here's the biggest problem
all these words you're using are just
forms of
suffering Pain's part of life suffering
you've heard is an option it really is
an option but what happens is when you
focus on yourself there's always
suffering so there's three things will
trigger your suffer if you think three
words lost less never if you think
something you did caused you to lose or
have less of or never have love or
respect or free time or Financial
Freedom or anything yeah I think that's
my one I think I feel that something
there was something I did that made it
that way yes and by the way people do
the opposite and some people do both
they look at what other people did what
the government did what this person did
what some system did something outside
thems that makes them believe they've
lost something or will never have
something when you think lost less never
about yourself the mind you're not your
mind right like it's like all the
thoughts you ever thought I want to kill
this mother F have you ever had that
thought yeah I don't do it but I do
think it but you but you just the key is
you don't do it I don't do it do you
think that's your thought are you the
first person to have that thought no how
long do you think that thought's been
around probably since the Bible I bet
probably before yeah right maybe before
yeah so if I told you 100 years ago or
Cain killed Abel in the Bible That's why
I said there yeah that's good point but
yeah and also there was definitely
people killing each other before that so
but but check this out think about this
for a second that thought is not your
thought you're being used by that
thought if I said 100 years ago there's
going to be a little box in your pocket
and you can pull it out and you'll be
able to touch it and see people on the
other side of the earth cuz there's
invisible waves going around the Earth
it's going to come in your box you go
read between the lines right
it's not going to happen but think about
or we're going to fly to the moon in
back they used to call the people who
said that lunatics that's where the term
comes from people thought we could go to
the Moon well we've been to the moon and
you now have a phone that does those
things well thoughts also have been
around forever and think of your body is
like cable you turn one channel and it
brings down a signal of Comedy another
channel it's a Horror Picture another
channel it's effing drama another
channel it's adventure
and so when you drop your body of this
you get a different channel of what you
see feel and tap into than if you're
like this or whatever your state is or
giggling or laughing and then you
get a different channel so the pattern
of how we use our body it determines
what part of the thoughts we tap into
but the biggest thing is if you're going
to be pissed off or sad at least get a
unique thought one you created don't
just copy everybody else every other
that ever lived they're just
copying it change your body change your
life change your story change your life
so you've already begun it uhhuh you've
gone through the chemistry of being
dissatisfied enough to say I'm not going
to do the drugs I'm going to start to
run now I'm kind of liking this feeling
but then you get pulled back a little
bit because it's new your old stuff you
know well and so you got to just cut it
off and again you could do that through
imer I'd love to have you come and be
one of my events and be my guest and
just have your own experience but
regardless you can still do it on your
own just by changing the Habit changing
the Habit you change it enough it's like
the more you go down a path the more it
gets wired they did this at the UC
Irvine they took monkeys they tape four
of their fingers down and then they
manually bend their finger like this
10,000 times well now they untape the
fing of the hands and what does the
monkey do right no kidding well you're
not a monkey but many people drive to
work the same way every day get on the
same subway and one day they're supposed
to go a different direction get off on a
different offramp but their brain so
used to it they get off on the wrong
off-ramp well that's kind of what you're
doing you're get off on the offramp of
some old pattern and so what you got to
do is stop going down that path start to
do it stop it stop so what they found by
the way you don't have to do 10,000
times imagine they found they could do
it with 12 of these instead of 10,000
get the same wiring and the way they did
it was they stimulate the pleasure
center of the brain so it's
like and each time they did it imagine
instead of one threat of connection
between neurons in the brain nerve cells
in the brain one instead when there's
joy there or excitement or pleasure you
get a thousand of them so they could do
12 and get the without emotion get the
same result of 10,000 m right so we wire
ourselves like you can so I have control
over that you're saying some people you
they don't even notice it though that
what was amazing to me for years I
didn't notice that's what I was doing
yeah well that's that's part of growing
right how old are you now may ask I'm 43
right so you know most people when
you're think of it this way 0 to 21 is
like springtime you don't have to figure
anything out you learn you grow things
occur you might have problems and upsets
but you know it's an interesting life 22
to 42 MH you're kind of the soldier of
society you go out and test what you've
been like I don't know if I believe the
I was told let me try this you
think by the way you're Invincible I'm
the president of United States a
multi-billionaire and have 100
relationships simultaneously and
everyone's going to be happy but
somewhere around 35 or 40 you know 45
you start going you know relationship's
hard and I'm not very good at this
and I'm not a billionaire yet well
what's the deal here and so then you
have to go on a journey the hero's
journey you're being called to go into
the unknown and try new things and if
you step into the unknown you'll meet
new mentors new people you'll learn to
slay the dragon you'll become the hero
in your own life but ages basically 43
to 63 that's the reaping time of your
life this is when you're coming brother
that's the stage of Life by the when
people are the most happy yeah right if
they're healthy and the Very happiest is
usually 64 to 84 if they're healthy and
people can live to 104 oldest people 120
but each stage has different problems
and different opportunities so you're
entering your power and it's showing up
right you got a large audience your your
humor become more playful more refined
but now you're like I want more I want
me to be happy look at you know you know
comedians that have killed themselves I
mean we can make a long list of people
that made everybody happy except
themselves oh when you yeah people think
of Robin Williams Brody Stevens um those
are just a few yeah and there could be a
bigger list I'm not good at thinking ofi
all those guys you back to go further
right you know so if you think about it
if you make everybody happy but yourself
I I always tell people success without
fulfillment is the ultimate failure and
so you're starting to go look I want to
be fulfilled too I don't want to just be
successful on the outside I want I want
this to be inside me and you're on the
path brother the way you get on the path
is you decide what you want and you
going to decide I want more than what I
had before Second Step you say okay
there's a gap between where I am or
where I want to be what's getting in the
way is it a fear I need to face is it a
habit is it an emotion what is it is it
a skill I'm missing I need to get I
don't know how to do this so someone's
got to show me so I can get better once
you have faed that you get a little plan
together and you start taking action not
a perfect plan and then you got to slay
your dragons you got to make the change
you gota okay so I'm not going to do the
drugs anymore okay I'm going to run
instead and then you get momentum yeah
and you're starting to get momentum so
now the only puts the break on your
momentum is those old emotional patterns
so you got to go that's not me that's an
old pattern F that here's what I'm going
to do now and here the other part though
as long as you focus on yourself you
suffer see suffering comes from focusing
on you wow that's why contribution
that's why contribution is so valuable
because when you're doing something for
others you're not thinking about you
unless you're trying to do it to get
something right and a lot of people had
to focus on themselves because it was a
survival mechanism so they didn't have a
choice right so some people you don't
even realize it your whole life you
might be focused on yourself and you
might think well I'm selfish but some of
that might be just old habits because
you had to focus on yourself to make
sure you were okay okay that's right but
then what happens is we don't update our
software be like it be like using one of
those old you know digital or not even
digital phones you be like what are you
doing you an idiot oh yeah using a
pencil yeah I mean what what are you
doing the world
[Music]
pervert but but you it's time to upgrade
your software and that's what you're
doing you're upgrading your mental
software yeah and there's some law I
think there's yeah there's a little bit
of sense of loss with letting go of the
old software because it felt like home
yeah exactly right and it's like I I'm
old enough I had one of the first phones
it was this Motorola phone you ever seen
it weigh like 8B it was like a buck a
minute and it didn't charge for more
than 20 minutes you call the police
too but I was so proud to have that
phone now like I me sting to I meant
sting it would call him was he in the
police yes if you give the if you give
if you got a phone today they'll give it
you for free as long as you got a
contract and you got everything on you
got 100,000 songs you got access to
everything so why would you go back to
the old oh I kind of miss it okay well
go get your on those phones you can go
visit it go put it in some part of your
house and go visit for a little while if
you want to but after a while you get
bored with it and you'll move into the
new stuff and that's what's happening
for you brother yeah once you evolve
into something new yeah once you make a
change it really does feel good it's
just hard to make it sometimes but I'll
tell you I'll tell you one more secret M
for changes to last it has to become
your identity let me explain we all have
a way of defining ourselves to ourselves
so for example if you see Lance
Armstrong right was the greatest biker
of all time he gets told that he has
cancer not just cancer cancer in his
lungs cancer in his brain and oh yeah in
your testicles oh by the way I ride a
bike for a living they told was going to
die but his core belief is I always find
the way so he survived cancer most
people don't he also found a way to win
no matter what he broke the rules to do
it that cost his brand and so forth but
the same thing that made him healthy
actually got him into trouble in the
biking side but before he used drugs he
was still unbelievable one of the best
in the world and guess what he got there
because of a belief so you have to have
a new identity his identity is I find
the way made him healthy so think of it
this way if I set the thermostat in this
room at I think it'll relate to this
let's say 68 degrees okay all right and
that's a metaphor for your comfort zone
your identity this is you know that's 68
degrees is how much not how much money I
want but what you know what I'm used to
68 degrees is what I'm used to in a
relationship it's not the it's not what
I want but you know it's okay you know
it's pretty good it's what I know you
know so think about as comfort zone now
if the temperature drops to 65 64 62 59
all of a sudden the brain the computer
goes hey you're a 68 degree or what are
you doing at 59 and I'm sure you've
experienced it like this is and
they like boom suddenly the heaters kick
on and you got drive and you go deal
with it you go lose the weight or you
get off the drugs you do whatever it is
but here's the part that most people
understand let's say you get back to
where you were and now you get new
momentum and you're doing better you go
to 69 70 80 89 9 99 degrees and all a
sudden the brain goes what the hell you
doing up here you're a 68 deger you're
not a 99 deger and the first thing that
happens is the heaters stop and you stop
growing and then that's not enough the
air conditioners kick on and you start
to sabotage yourself till you get back
to where you believe you are so
cigarettes if you you used to smoke
right so if I came to you today and I
offer you a cigarette what would you say
yes sir say nobody or nobody no sir no
no sir no sir nobody okay you know so
why cuz I don't want it yeah why cuz I
don't doesn't make me happy anymore yeah
most people have I you wouldn't say what
brand is it you go no and the reason why
is you're no longer a smoker it's not
your identity ah if you thought you're a
smoker you might go what brand is it
well maybe I'll have one you know do
whatever it is right it's like when
people tell me you know I'm on day four
of not drinking or not smoking I'm go
why you counting so you can tell people
how many days you last this time before
you go back again it's like when you
change your identity I'm not one of
those you're not going to do it anymore
so you are in the midst of transforming
your identity you're in the middle of it
right now and you're doing a beautiful
job I'm not again blowing smoke I'm not
a thanks man I no but I hope
you take it in because you need to own
that on your own your own instincts have
led you to a place of real progress
you're not there yet not where you want
to be and by when you get wherever there
is it won't be enough you'll want to do
more because we're all supposed to keep
growing that's what makes us happy yeah
I want to keep learning I think it's
it's important and I like learning about
why people feel certain ways yeah that
is like uh and so does a lot of our our
listeners it's important to a lot of us
yes um let me tell you why people feel a
lot of us we we don't get understanding
nobody kind of explains to you what's
going on yeah while you're feeling so it
gets confusing you know so like yeah I
don't know that I'm changing and I'm
feeling sad about you know just that I
don't know some of the but let me give
you let me give you and your viewers
three things cuz what I spent decades so
many things I will say you got a lot of
things though but it's good I'm loving
them I got I got Decades of taking
complex things that make them simple
because apprciate complexity is the
enemy of execution if it's too complex
you don't do it right that's exactly
what I'm just saying yeah it's to so let
me give you three you can think about
this for you and your viewers whatever
you're feeling right now whether you're
pissed off or sad or frustrated or
excited or passionate whatever it
doesn't matter there's only three things
that made you feel that way three
patterns the first pattern is what
you're doing with your body so let me
give you an example if I said there's a
depressed person behind curtain number
one over there and I'll give a 100,000
donation to your favorite charity I bet
you could describe them physically
without seeing them depressed person
where are their shoulders probably down
forward where's their head probably
looking like probably maybe something
like that that's right are they talking
loud or quiet there could be probably a
little bit bit subdued maybe that's
right fast or slow um probably slow
that's right and when they're doing that
think about why do you know that because
you've practiced this before we all
have right but if you take that same
person and I do this over and over again
and you change what we call their
physiology the way they move the way
they breath they put their shoulders
back they breathe different it literally
changes their biochemistry if you change
that as a habit you change the
biochemistry on a regular basis better
than a drug because you're not dependent
upon anything second thing determines
how you feel so you're your own drug
right and you're the dealer and the user
exactly right so if you're excited
what's a body like yeah you're a little
more pumped up yeah is your head up or
down up yeah where your
shoulders they're there they're good
yeah they're loose it's
they're doing what they want that's
right is the voice monotone or does it
have more variety to it variety that's
right right so you think about that
you're breathing more full or more
shallow more full that's right when
you're depressed it's more yeah probably
more shallow except for some occasional
big ones to get you keep you down there
that's right well you let it all out and
deflate right so we change your
breathing we change your movement change
your posture and your entire
biochemistry will change that fast but
people have habits how they use like
there's 37 muscles in your your face
this is the largest era of unemployment
in the country because people do the
same facial expression over and and they
feel the same feelings over and over
again you change the body you change it
all now the second thing you change is
what you focus on so example I gave you
if you're thinking about oh my God
they're not here or they're in a car
accident you're a worrior if you think
they don't give a and they did it
again you're going to be pissed off so
whatever you focus on you feel even if
it's not true you will feel it and then
the third one is the language you put to
it because words change meaning so if I
said to you look during the break we
have some nutritious snacks the audience
goes you know I got some delicious
snacks oh interesting just one word
change changes the biochemistry it's not
the words other people say to you it's
also the words you say to yourself that
change your biochemistry and it's not
just words there's certain phrases that
change what you even perceive so I don't
know if you've ever had this when you
were a kid but I remember you know I I
finally get to sit down and have dinner
and I was responsible for all of making
the they're doing it all and then my mom
or dad would say could you get the salt
just said I don't know what the salt is
and I'm not lying I don't know the exact
GPS location of the salt right I know
where the salt is and you know where the
salt is the kitchen go get the salt I
know where the salt you go get the salt
fine oh my God what am I saying in my
head I know where the salt is I know
where the salt is it's it's over on the
second shelf I open it I know I'm really
looking I don't know where the salt is
it's not here my dad walks by reaches
right in front of my face and goes what
is this you ever had an experience like
that so here's the question did your
eyes see the salt no yes they did but
your brain did allow you to perceive it
because you hypnotized yourself over and
over again telling the lie to yourself I
don't want to Salt this I to Sal this so
it doesn't want to turn you into a liar
yourself so it's called a sketa a blind
spot so when you tell me yourself but I
don't want to lose those friends of mine
from the past that made me feel like
and you do it over and over again
you can't even see the other option
that's why our language our focus and
our physiology the three of them
together control if you make a little
change in your body you'll feel a little
change in how you feel but for example
sound you do you like to sing when no
one's around uh not that much I'm not a
great singer no I'm not either but when
no one's around like in the car great
song something like that sometimes yeah
yeah so some people they most of us
don't sing well so what happens we're in
the car we're singing we're rocking
we're rapping right you get the the spot
SPL you're still doing look over a car
next to you somebody staring at you you
pick up your cell phone act like you've
been talking to somebody or some
but what's happened is it makes you feel
good to sing because you're using parts
of your body you don't normally use they
lift it lifts you emotionally and so
what happens is that's why even though
you don't sound good people like to sing
when no one's around but when somebody's
around they don't want to sing because
they want to be judged yeah right so you
can change your focus your language and
your physiology wow if you change all
three you make a radical change so when
we do like a seminar and they have the
firewalk M the firewalk is just a
metaphor for breaking through whatever
stops you but when you get in front of
2,000 Dee burning hot coals you have a
state change like all day you might have
found really good they're like oh my I
can't do it I can't do it I can't do
when I look at him I go I couldn't do it
either if I talk like this and put my
shoulders like this I say Stand Tall put
your shoulders back scream yes yes
scream yes and I yes yes I said go and
then boom the person who couldn't go 10
seconds ago storms across the fire
because what we do is based on the state
Ren and you can change your state by the
way you move by what you focus on and by
the language you use change all three
radically again and again you change
your life Wow Tony man thank you so much
for thinking about this stuff with this
I know that you have before you go I
know you have a book that's coming out
the Holy Grail right yes is it okay if
we pivot to that for five minutes sure
I'd love to okay so I know it's about
finances right and it's about the
disparity in the world kind of yeah well
I don't I've written Three Financial
books this is the third one of the
trilogy the final the trilogy okay and
the first one was money Master the game
it's most uh most read most successful
Financial book of the last 23 years I'm
really proud of it wow but as time went
by I wrote that book by interviewing 50
of the smartest Financial people in the
world and saying how do I take this
complex stuff make it some my
billionaire clients love it but the
average person can really use it and it
shows you how to go from nothing to
where you want to be then I wrote a book
called unshakable to prepare people for
2020 I didn't know it was going to be Co
but I knew there was going to be a giant
market change because because you can
predict that it's going to come we don't
know when but it's going to come and I
wanted people prepared and then now
there's so many people unprepared for
their financial future that they're in
the hole and so in order to get where
you want to go you need compounding with
a tiny amount of money compounding you
can get wherever you want like right you
know if you start when you're really
young you're 19 you save you have no
overhead save 300 bucks a month and you
put it you know let's say in the stock
market where it's an 8% return you can
go from 17 to 27 you put very little
money in right 3,000 bucks a year
roughly but that money will grow over
time to provide several million dollars
if you stopped at 27 years old you start
at 28 and do it you got to put money in
until you're 65 and you'll still have
less money that's how compounding works
right so it doesn't take a lot but if
you could compound with a higher rate of
return without taking too much risk
because you take too much risk risk you
lose everything right and is that higher
rated return still so it feels like
there's not as much it feels very risky
these days or it feels like the stock
market like it's just a front-facing
thing to the public where everything
else is done behind the scenes I think
that's what a lot of stuff starts to
feel like well and and there are some
truth to that because there used to be
8,000 stocks now there's only 3,600 and
most of them like in the Russell 2000
which is one of the you know the young
companies 40% of them aren't even
profitable when you look at what's
called the S&P 500 the list of the top
500 companies in the stock market there
that S&P lists those are the best ones
there's about seven that represent about
80% of the profits of what's going on
there wow so it's a very small number
that has changed over time and we didn't
used to people used to in order to
protect themselves if you went to
financial planner they'd say we'll put
this much in stocks and this much in
bonds because there's something called
correlation or non-correlation when
things move the same direction if you
invest in both of them and they both go
down you got nothing if they both go up
it's nice but when they go down it's a
problem so I met with this man ray doio
some of your viewers may have heard of
him Ray doio Ray doio he's the greatest
hedge fund investor in history he
manages almost $200 billion doll in
business oh wow and I interviewed him 14
years ago and became good friends and I
asked him a question one time this guy's
a genius he literally manages money for
countries and he's got the greatest
track like 2008 when everybody the
market went down whatever was it 38%
whatever the number I forget the exact
number he was down 3% damn right and by
the end of the year he made %. good job
I mean just brilliant guy so I I asked
Ray I said what is the most important
investment principle that the average
person or a billionaire would want to
know what's made you so successful the
most important principle and he didn't
even hesitate goes Tony I spent 20 years
to figure this out he goes I'm going to
tell you the answer and he said it's
called the Holy Grail right he goes the
Holy Grail of investing is to find 8 to
12 Investments that are not correlated
so let me explain stocks are designed to
go up and then bonds where they are if
stocks go down bonds usually go up but
in 2020 they both went down 2008 they
both went down and so they don't that
doesn't always work and so you've got a
lot of risk he said the secret is if you
can find 8 to 12 Investments that are
not correlated you reduce your risk 80%
wow and you increase your upside there
is nothing on Earth that's more
important you're you can try to pick the
right stock or the right Bond or the
right piece of real estate but you're
going to be wrong you're going to try
and do the right time you're going to be
wrong the one thing you can count on is
reducing the risk that you're write more
often and he said that that reduces the
risk about the most by 8 to 12
Investments 8 to 12 they're not
correlated so what are some examples of
just places that things wouldn't be
correlated well that's why I wrote this
book because the average person thinks
okay well I got stocks and bonds and
maybe your REITs or real estate and the
problem is even reats often will go up
and down with the stock market right so
I've been around a while I've worked
with the best people in the world and I
I you know I've done well financially
and so I get opportunities at times
because I'm well aware of the fact that
private Equity private real estate
private private credit are actually much
bigger businesses for the last 35 years
hear this for everybody okay for the
last 35 years private Equity firms have
done better than every stock market in
the world on average better than average
of all those so example the S&P 500 the
one that most people know in the United
States that they you know will invest in
if you put that that's over the last 35
years has gone up 99.2% compounded on
average per year so you put your money
in and it keeps growing it's pretty nice
pretty swell yeah but if you an average
not by the way when I went to interview
people for this I interviewed the 13
biggest private Equity guys in the world
who run hundred billion dollars right
who make more money than than God
basically the smartest ones in the world
so to find out what they're doing
because these guys all make like 20%
plus per year not 14 and a half so 9.2
versus 14.2 14.2 is the average private
Equity these are not average that's 50%
better per year to grow your finances on
let me put that into what people
understand understand when you compound
what that means if you put a million
dollars 35 years ago on the stock market
it's worth 26 million right now it's
unbelievable but if you put a million in
private Equity it's worth 129 million
same money same amount of time God yeah
so it's like so so most people know they
don't know that much yeah but they know
private Equity does really well one of
the reasons is your money's tied up for
five years so if the market goes up and
down they don't have to go sell so when
the Mark goes down they buy right and
they build they buy a company they build
it up they make it more valuable and
they sell it to another company or they
take it public and they when things are
good they sell them when things are not
they buy so they've got a lot of room
and they make money a lot of ways if you
put your money into these firms they get
2% of your money every year no matter
what for managing it oh W they make
money or lose it so if they have a
billion dollar fund they make 20 million
a year for five years they have $100
million guaranteed before they open
their mouth then they get 20% of The
Upside if they help it to grow it's not
uncommon for these guys to go from a
billion to two billion in five years
that means they make 20% of that
addition billion they make another $200
million they make $300 million on what
originally was a billion so when you
look at the Fords 400 the richest people
in the world and you say are they Tech
guys are they real estate guys no the
number one are Financial Services it's
private Equity so watch this this is
mindboggling because this sounds like
it's all for rich people that's what I
want to tell you okay I'm just saying
that so no and you're right and it has
been but here's what's changed Congress
the house just passed a law bipartisan
that said the richest people in the
world having access to this is not fair
M and the argument has been well it's
more sophisticated well they came up
with a way to do it which is you made
money money building a business you
don't know about investing but you get
to make these Investments if you can get
in they passed the law that now says and
now house has done it Christmas
vacations just come they're coming back
and they're going to vote in the Senate
looks like it's going to pass there as
well you can take a test I can show you
a study for you pass the test you get
access to these things but there's
another problem access because it's like
buying an exotic car if you you got like
a uh you know one of the new Ferraris
not not a standard one of you know one
of the high-end Ferraris there's a line
of people waiting they buy them all just
like that so it's not enough you have
money you got to know the right people
so these funds you know as I got more
money and I was more famous I knew
people I could get into some of these
funds but I could get a sliver some I
couldn't even get in there already sold
out I like I was so frustrated so one
day I'm talking to my friend Paul tutor
Jones's a partner that broke off and
started his own business and I was
basically saying this is so frustrating
because these opportunities are so huge
but I've got resources but I can't even
get in yeah he said Tony I'm going to
tell you a little secret I'll tell you
where I put most of my money and I'm
leaning forward because this is a big
big player right yeah yeah get the
shovel huh tell tell me tell me what it
is and he he goes there's this company
in Texas that does something really
unique there's a few but they're the
best I've seen it's in Texas you
normally you hear Singapore London New
York right he in Connecticut he goes
yeah he said Tony you don't have to
fight to become an investor in one of
those funds he said when you are an
investor in a private Equity they call
you a limited partner that's the legal
name they use for it okay the owner of
the fund and private Equity just what
explain what it is really fast it's
buying companies that are not public
okay which is most companies right and
you build it they put money in it they
bring new CEO they build a new team they
do a new marketing they make the company
stronger and they sell it when you sell
a business you get a multiple on the
profits okay got it so you're investing
in those sorts of things that's private
Equity that's right and they have funds
that invest over a period of time and
they
but they're not open to the public well
they're open to the public but usually
they're gone if they're really good oh
they're really gone they're gone right
right away right so he says to me he
goes Tony you can become an owner in the
business itself and all those funds not
just own a fund and you can get the same
two and 20 like you earn the 2% in 20
you'll make about 10% on your investment
per year as an owner oh wow and you get
all the funds past present and future
the ones they did was low inflation the
ones at high inflation the future ones
they want to do I'm like how do you do
that he goes I'm going introduce you to
these guys called Cass Caz they're based
out of Houston so I meet this guy it
turns out 25 years ago he started his
career using my stuff and started this
business he's been incredibly successful
he's one of the biggest it's called GP
Stakes you own a general partnership
stake you're an owner you get the
benefit of an owner and you own all the
funds so I now own a piece of 65
different funds and they're not little
funds they're not billion dollar funds
they're 100 billion funds like Vista
they have1 billion doll and they're
growing like we and I get huge income
like I'm an owner and I get the upside
like an owner and I get what an investor
would get all the same and you say well
why would they do that are they wanting
to retire no years ago they used to just
get companies and try to leverage them
and sell them for pieces that's old
business Nobody Does that anymore they
build them but they have to put their
own money in too so investors go if
you're on the line with me I will invest
more so there was a company called Bane
that after 2008 when people were shaky
they said we're going to raise $4
billion but we're going to put 800
million of our own money in that's kind
of the standard now so if you're putting
money in you open a new fund every
couple years and it's tied up for five
years your cash flow can be tight so
some they want more money to keep
growing so if you know the right people
you can do things so now I'm a part of
that but anyone can become a part of
that all the it's ignorance is not Bliss
right ignorance is poverty knowing this
changes the game I'll give you another
one so people can learn that in this
book though yeah explain exactly how to
do it okay and then um another one like
all these Rings right for years I want
you know I wanted to be a professional
athlete I wasn't good enough so it
didn't work out well but then I was like
wow I got to work with all these
athletes and turn them around some the
best in the world you know you I get to
visit with a guy like Tom Brady go you
know go work with all these guys you
know see what they're like and what
they're doing well I started turning
these teams around and I started getting
the championship rings that I would have
had but I've got them here from hockey
I've got them here from NBA I've got
them all these dreams came true in this
all a whole different way I mean how
many people like Michael Jordan a few
other people have six MVP rings I got
six rings e anyway especially if it's a
man you know unless they're Italian if
it's a man you know unless they're 100%
like but they're cherishing me but
here's what I'm tell you so then I was
like I want to own a sports team you
know I finally got enough money to
participate and I finally uh you know
then they they take a microscope to for
a year to do it it's unbelievable and so
I helped build the lafc football club I
was one of the original investors in it
it's great but now there's a new rule
that's come about in the last couple
years it's specialized and it allows you
to buy a piece even a tiny piece of
multiple sports teams and be an owner
and the reason you want to do it is this
Sports is not tied to the stock market
it's non-correlated stock market goes up
or down doesn't affect sports sports
have done well during recessions
depressions player strikes covid
everything they've still done well to
return from from Major League Baseball
from the NHL from the NBA and from
soccer those four spots keeps growing
has averaged at 18 % a year in the last
10 years so it's twice as much as the
stock market to give you an idea and
it's fun but here's the best part
they're no longer just putting butts in
seats and they have a legal Monopoly
they can they own that City no one else
can compete with them and their fans
word fan comes from Fanatics their
customers are Fanatics multiple
Generations so my friend Peter goober he
bought the Dodgers with my other friend
Magic Johnson and a group of other
people and no one had PID he paid $2
billion to LA Dodgers two billion no one
had paid a billion for a team yet and
everybody said it should have been a
billion overpaid by a billion so I went
to Peter and I said Peter I know you're
no dumb he's my partner in businesses we
own sports team together lafc and I said
uh you got to tell me the secret because
I know you're not dumb you're not going
to overpay by a billion dollars that's a
lot he says to me he goes Tony you know
he's made 52 Academy Award made movies
he's a total genius so he said you know
I'm not dumb you're right he goes tell
you what I want to leave you in suspense
I'm going to make an announcement in two
days days then you call me come on over
and we'll laugh together so sure enough
two days later they announce he paid two
billion for the team he sold the local
TV rights for $7 billion and made 5
billion instantly no way then just for
the soccer no that's for football I
excuse me for the LA Dodgers oh for the
Dodgers he sold the rights yeah so s
billion now you also when you own a
sports team the NBA MLB Major League
Baseball whatever you get a piece of the
ad revenue for every single team doesn't
matter if big or small so his local
rights alone made him 5 billion so you
probably saw the the gentleman he just
brought on of Shani yes and Sh is that
his name sh yeah and his and I'm sh sh
the amount of money the amount of money
he's being paid is more than anybody in
history wow and how are they doing it
well they're doing it because they know
that the ad Revenue they get from
Japanese advertisers so forth will pay
it times many more do you know if you
watch television today because of cord
cutting nobody wants to watch
commercials so 92 of the last 100 top
shows are sports because you don't have
think about making a film for Netflix
like a series you got to pay actors all
that's gone you set up your cameras you
shoot it's cheap to do and people are
willing to watch because it's live and
then they'll watch the ads just like the
Super Bowl right people watch all the
ads so it that business and they buy the
real estate around it they become media
Moguls so now I own the Warriors I own
the Dodgers I own the Red Sox I own the
Pittsburgh Penguins because you have a
piece in what what I which I teach in
this book it's a piece of these
different businesses these Sports
businesses and it's non-correlated
people can get into that shows you how
to do it and you can do a tiny amount
small amounts I'll give you one last one
bonds you're not probably not very
familiar with because you haven't done a
lot they caught him what did he
do oh not talking about no I'm sorry I'm
talking about stock stocks and bonds oh
sorry yes no problem but bonds for years
because of low interest rates have given
you no return so people are taking
bigger and bigger risks so back in 2021
you know you're making no money so
there's a type of bond that is not very
stable it's very risky and they call
them high yield bonds they're actually
called Junk bonds because they're very
risky they were paying 3.9% in 2021
before the interest rates rise and
people were buying them because there's
no other place to get income I was
making 9% on private credit what is
private credit yes Banks don't loan to a
lot of people people really high-end
businesses 100 million to3 billion
businesses need money to grow mhm well
where do they go they go to private
credit now these organizations now loan
you money and they usually loaned it you
know just a few years ago at like 5% 6%
for a loan so banks are borrowing money
from people no companies need to borrow
money from Banks and Banks don't do it
Apple will get their money somebody like
that right but a lot of businesses won't
there's 200,000 business in the United
States between 100 million and 3 billion
to give you an idea gigantic they need
money so there's become a new market
it's these private Equity guys loaning
them money but they put their own money
in it so they don't sell the loan off so
they are really picky about who they put
in and they build good long-term
relationships they have less than a 1%
failure rate no Bank on Earth has that
they'd be dreaming about that there
though you know if you I'll give you an
example that may your audience can
relate to if you had a house you had a
mortgage that was fixed when interest
rates went up you don't care you're
still it's only 3% but when you bought a
loan a business is usually a floating
rate so when interest rates go it rises
up so those same private credit firms
that loaned you money at three and a
half% guess what excuse me five or 6%
now it's 11% plus the same loan with the
same company and you're making twice or
three times as much money as before so
when people are taking risks at 3.9% I'm
got a 1% failure rate and I'm making 9%
now I'm in the high teens on my private
credit and I own those firms so I also
get the 2% get the 20% and I get the
upside on those pieces so those are just
three examples I give you seven examples
of industries that you can do and show
you exactly how to do it and then the
second half of the book is these 13
Masters of the Universe these guys that
you know like Robert Smith who runs
Vista it's a famous firm hundred billion
dollars in business he started with he
started with nothing he's a the
wealthiest african-america in the United
States Genius of man I love this man oh
hell yeah that's cool he he focuses on
one industry and software as a service
called SAS but he knows it so well that
he can take a company he already knows
what to do with a CEO what to do how to
grow it he grows it rapidly he's got a
whole system for doing it he grows the
business and then he sells it to a
bigger company or takes it public his
returns I can't quote his returns
because you have to ask him about it but
they're all above 20% for decades wow
for decades so think about what that
would do to your financial future what
would have taken say 10 years to double
you can do in three years and so this
isn't the only thing you do but it's one
of the most important things that most
people don't know about and it was never
available before now it's available
you're saying because of the new
legislation a lot of this stuff is
available that's correct and is there
downside to it I mean there's risk with
everything yeah that's right well least
amount of risk compared to bonds less
okay but then the second other than say
treasuries on the private Equity side
again since they have your money for a
longer period you get a lot larger
return but there's less risk the reason
there's less risk is because when things
drop in the stock market they don't have
to sell they go buy Vin right when
things are up they go sell Vin so they
have more room to play Within time
instead of oh my God what I going to do
this quarter what I going do get the
stock up this day they don't have to do
that it allows them to make better
decisions got it um they had um by way
we give aund my last three books I've
done this given 100% of of all the
profits in the book go to feeding
America so while you're helping yourself
you'll help people that are really in
need as well same for this one the
profits are going to that oh that's
amazing man thank you that's cool man I
uh I eat you so I know we're all
grateful for that you know can I get a
copy of the book too of course I sweet
man yeah of course um there's like this
is my last question so there is we're
we're kind of at a time in the world
where I think a lot of people are under
a little bit it's a precarious time it
feels like right un a lot of uncertainty
some of that may be media influence some
of it may not we don't know but there's
just a lot going on there's a lot going
on and it used to feel like you could
leave world a better place right it used
to be something that I think gave people
a lot of purpose right like I'm I want
to leave the world a better place and I
think
now there sometimes feels like the
you're the world has
gotten it's flared up yeah and we can't
do that I'm not saying it's true but it
sometimes it feels like that and so I
think that caused a lot of people to it
really takes away a sense of purpose at
a level probably an almost limic or
animal level that we don't even realize
yeah what can people
do to combat that the first thing I do
is I would cut down my consumption of
the news turn off all the things that go
on your phone not to become a Hermit or
something but you got to remember the
news people are good people they don't
have bad intent but they have to do one
thing they're doing their job their job
is make more money for the shareholders
there's only one way to do that get more
of your eyeballs how do I get your
eyeballs upset you anger you produce
fear if I do those things we all know in
journalism they talk if it beds it leads
right it used to be again a plane
crashed in Nigeria you didn't know about
it now you know about it within seconds
so it's there's actually all the studies
show there's less violence today but we
see everything more magnified right
we're also in a stage in kind of History
we go through stages and I don't want
try to be complex to explain the whole
thing to you but if you study a thousand
years of Roman history 500 years of
Anglo American history we go through 18
20 year Cycles where where we run an
emotion as a culture as a whole doesn't
mean you're going to feel that way so in
the springtime everybody's optimistic I
don't mean physical spring I mean that
season right and things grow and it's
easy so like after World War II we went
in springtime everybody's like oh thank
God it's over everybody had lots of sex
that was the baby boom right oh yeah you
know if you were if you were a veteran
you were like you got to have a house
for free right no money down that thing
it was a cool time for a lot of people
not everyone but a lot of people yeah
yeah the culture right but then from
1945 to 1963 and 63 for the height of
optimism Kennedy's the President johnf
Kennedy and he gets assassinated and
then Robert Kennedy and then Martin
Luther King and what happens is we go
through a summertime where everything's
tested and there's fighting within the
country there's it's called Summer it's
like it happens every 80 years like
clockwork I can take you there's a
there's a really cool book is it the
Strauss how generational theory is that
it that's it that's it you guys got it
so if you read St Howen about
generational Theory there's there's a
book called the fourth turning that I
interviewed these guys turning fourth
turning it's a book worth reading cuz
what you'll be reading about how life is
and it's like right now and then they
reveal it from 80 years ago from The New
York Times and then you read another one
it's from 160 years ago and you're like
this is crazy so it's a cycle that we go
through so after we're done with the
optimism we get burnt out we go through
the summer of test and upset then we
have another good time we have fall
where everything's easy you want a house
you have no money we'll give you a loan
right my buddy easy easy money right and
everything's easy then that's always
followed by a winter now some Winters
are long some are short some are hard
some are relatively easy but you never
go from Fall to Spring youve got to go
through winter right we're in Winter
right now so think about it the people
that were growing up in try this for
size most people don't study their
history but just take this for a second
if you were born in like 1910 what did
that mean well World War I was going on
while you were growing up so you were
protected you didn't go to war you
didn't have to face it your family
looked out for you it have been a tough
time but you made it through it and we
won the war and came home right around
that time like now there's a massive
technology breakthrough like we're
experiencing with AI and so forth what
happened we went from nothing to radios
televisions cars planes like and the
Roaring 20s so if you're growing up and
you're in that 0 to 21 you were born in
1910 you're thinking when I'm 1920 I'm
getting a car I'm in a party and the
kids then were looked down on they were
called Flappers cuz they were
irresponsible very much like older
Generations often talk about Millennials
or
Millennials are great people but they
haven't faced anything really big they
think violence is words right you know
Chris Rock says if you think violence
are words no one slapped the out of
you on National Television that's
violence that's a different thing right
so but when you've never experienced
anything you think that's pain because
that's your idea of pain right so
they're right about that but I have no
worries these are going to be the heroes
Millennials and z's are going to be
heroes of the future here's how I know
it 1910 when they turned 19 and they
thought they're going to go party what
happened it was 1929 and the whole world
was upside down suddenly people are
jumping out of building standing in food
lines the Midwest is a dust ball stock
market crash everything so these people
had to get tough they were weak as
but they had to get tough because it was
required to survive so by the way they
do 10 years of the depression it's not
bad every day there were some ups and
downs but pretty rough times lot of soup
lot of soup that's a good one but now
they turned 29 it's 1939 and that's when
World War II breaks out and you and I
weren't alive then but Hitler was taking
countries one after it looks like we're
going to lose yeah they fought that war
and one they became what's known as the
great generation the greatest Generation
cuz they face these difficult things
well at the end of the winter it's
springtime at Springtime once we got
through that then we went through a hot
summer think of how the 60s and 70s are
so different than the 80s 90s or 2000s
right and so we go through these Cycles
so we're in Winter right now and winter
makes it look much worse than it is but
here's the good news about winter it's
going to take that younger generation
and they're going to become Heroes
they're smart they're connected they
care but they're not as strong as they
will be because they have it's like
lifting weights you take a light weight
and lift it I don't care how many you do
a 100 curls you're not going to get
anything yeah you take a weight you can
barely lift and do you can only do eight
eight curls and your trainer makes you
do 11 and you that 11th curl gives you
90% of the growth we're going to go
through that experience we already are
to some extent but what people need is
to create a compelling future they need
to know that this went no war is forever
no economy is forever no you know plan
pandemic or planemic is forever don't
get addicted to the story don't fall in
that's a trap that's right so you also
have to have a plan for yourself and you
can see that like if you were the
universe or God after the night you
create the day you know it's like it
works and that's what makes us grow and
and winter also gets rid of the weak and
strong not only survive but they find a
way to thrive when you look at the
biggest companies in the world that
called Fortune 1000 M 80% excuse me 70%
of them were developed during a
recession or a depression wow because
when you do well then you're going to do
well during all the other Seasons so if
you start a business right now and it's
hard you do it well like I started my
business during the last really tough
time which was when interest rates were
18% nuh they were really that 18% I'm
not lying today if you people are
freaking out going 7% oh my God I can't
get a house try I bought my first house
at 18 years old it was 18% you're not
going to make any money at 18% I lost
money out the house it was horrible
right but that's what it was in those
days but I had to get strong and here I
am 46 years later and I've done very
well well a lot of other people started
when it was easy and they're gone yeah
wow so that's good it's a good way to
look at it man I think it goes back to
what we said in the beginning just talk
kind of about perspective you know yes
like have a perspective perspective have
a bigger perspective have a bigger
perspective of what's going on in your
own life um man I don't think there's
anything else you guys think of anything
I think we've spent a lot of your time
too and and we're I really enjoyed this
Theo yeah me too and I really and listen
I Lov your humor but I really want to
thank you for your vulnerability because
I you got a lot of people watching you
and you're you're leading by example I'm
not being perfect I'm not saying you're
supposed to I'm not perfect nobody is
yeah but you're growing brother and and
those emotions you felt you're going to
feel those a lot less as you keep on
this track pretty soon there won't be
something you identify with you it'll be
like cigarettes you'll be like I I by
the way do you feel bad about the
cigarettes that you're no longer there
with them you've left them behind I
don't miss them yeah you're not going to
miss those negative emotions you it's
like I go like you know go like just you
know do go visit them hey dude I'm sorry
or use a Ouija board like to talk to a
pack of winstons or something you know
yeah I don't do anything like that I'm
glad to hear that but thank you man
thank you for taking some time and to uh
just help us learn about that because I
think a lot of my listeners are really
similar to me and so I'm grateful for
that and I hope I hope they join me
because it's free hope I have a got oh
that's January 25th to 27th and um all
they got to do is go to timeo rise.com
timet rise.com register no cost to it
and then it's about about 3 hours a day
for 3 days in a row and you'll be blown
away it'll give you a new momentum for
your New Year dude I'll say this sitting
listening to Tony is really really
interesting even just being here so if
this is anything what it's like um at
the summit that's cool man so yeah I'm
excited about it man January 25th to
27th I know my my good friend Aaron lvie
goes has been to a couple of them and um
time
to.com time toise summit.com and we'll
put the link right here Below guys yeah
we'll put the link everywhere and we'll
share it we proba about a million
million and half people will do it from
all over the all over the world 195
countries so you'll meet some cool
people too online too which is kind of
fun cool man well thank you for first of
all just learning about stuff over your
life but also being willing to share it
I think you know when we don't share
stuff it's like it keeps things from
other people that's right so um it's
been I think a lot of people have have
have been uh helped by that and so thank
you so much thank you man it's been
great yeah cheers brother now I'm just
floating on the breeze and I feel I'm
falling like these leaves I'm must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of my life
found I can feel it in my
bones but it's going to
take